oh yeah thank you good morning welcome
along to this Workshop ltp workshop for
asset and activity plans
um welcome to those who are joining us
on the live stream
uh just a reminder that the discussion
today
um
is is all around open and transparent
decision making
um and then to that point we don't
actually have any decisions that we're
making uh we're having discussions so
for those people who are joining on the
live stream and think that this is where
we're making the decisions no this is
where we kick off discussions and
prepare the documents that will come to
council at a larger point and that's
where the decisions are made councilors
you can express opinions but really it's
all about keeping an open mind by the
time we come to making decisions
um there's no public involvement in the
workshops it's a chance for both
councilors and monofino representatives
to discuss the matters the public
consultation follows later
uh I've got apologies from councilor
Stewart and uh also from Reverend cook
no others so I'll move they're accepted
seconded rare
um so thank you for making the time
available today I know it's a long day
and uh Rhiannon I'll pass over to you or
Adina is going to
excellent same purpose uh so Stephen the
Big Ridge here is yours welcome along as
we um start off with an overview of
aquatic services
uh morning everyone
um all right
seriously now just forgive me I haven't
been already working these very often
hey there we go
um so aquatic Services the activity
um is to provide health and well-being
services to the community
um people can come and learn to swim
play sports
um and engage in recreational sort of
activity
um some of the sports that we sort of
host just in case anyone doesn't isn't
aware of what we have there
um we have water polo canoe Polo
springboard diving which is a new one
that just started up this year
um
underwater hockey Synchro
um just just to name a few so
there's there's other things that happen
there we have tri-clubs that come in and
all that sort of stuff so if it's quite
a busy sort of place
um
we are sort of the the largest
Aquatic Facility in Southland obviously
um in south of Dunedin
and um
just sort of where people can come and
enjoy the you know the hydrosides diving
boards that sort of stuff so just just
some safe
um indoor fun for Southland as we as we
need in this climate
so for
um aquatic services to align with our
strategic priorities and the community
outcomes
uh we need to look at changing the focus
to accommodate more recreational
activities for a rangitahi so that's
freeing up more diving board time
creating more space and other areas of
the pool for them to engage in at the
right times so you know evenings and
weekends
but also acknowledging the changing
demands of the community where we have
an agent population
Rehabilitation accessibility into our
pools is is restricted so we need to
look at how we can
cater for that
we need to ensure that our financial
barriers are not restricted in our
participation
by keeping the emission costs affordable
um
if cut we are one of the sort of one of
the dearer ones
um in in the South Island not the
dearest but one of the deer ones and it
is a barrier to
participation so if we increase the cost
too much then we could see a decrease in
participation in within the community
yeah
and then providing a safe environment
for people to enjoy that is inclusive of
everyone
uh so the current budget for this
financial year
um
we have an operational expenditure of uh
3.8 million and an operational Target
Revenue take of 3.8 million with a rates
draw of approximately uh 953 000.
um
we have
27 full-time equivalent staff
most of those are made up of
part-timers and casuals although we have
about sort of 15 full-time staff as well
so average account and totals around
about 75. and that's important to we can
maintain that moving forward for the
safety of our users
so maintaining our levels of service
to align with the Strategic priorities
and Community outcomes for the 2324 and
Beyond there's
um we have some issues to that need to
be addressed
um
and some of the options that could be
increasing our participation levels
looking at alternative funding and
revenue streams
um our our Revenue Target for those
years is quite ambitious
um at around about 2.6 2.7 million
um
just put that into context the last
Financial Year we're sitting around
about two million dollars which is the
best course done since it's opened
so we are always
trying to do better so we do that
um
you know try to meet targets but we have
to be realistic at the same time
so that's a reforecast the revenue down
to about 2.3 which still gives us a good
Target to achieve uh higher than what we
we did last year
um but also looking at how that affects
future years as well
um Staffing is always an issue for
Splash Palace we tend to employ quite a
young staff
so we can employ people from 16.
um genuinely average age is about 21.
um or slightly younger
um there's probably by myself
um
the we we have an inability to attract
um older staff that want to have a
career in the Leisure sort of um
services or leisure activities
and we're also competing with other jobs
right miter 10 Kmart in supermarkets
so I noticed um last week you know
countdown was advertising roles for 25
an hour which is competing with with our
staff as well so
you pull that market understand
can you pull that microphone out a
little closer thanks
sorry
um yeah so countdown advertising rolls
for about 25 now which is competes with
us we have quite a
responsibility for our staff to maintain
people's safety provide rescues perform
first aid and that sort of stuff so
there's a high expectation of them to
perform
whereas in other jobs you know there's
that
life-saving or the rescuing and
potentially saving someone life and
doing CPR doesn't always sort of fit in
with their
um their work
um the recruitment time for a fully
trained life trained lifeguard from uh
recruitment through to
um or sorry from advertisement through
to recruitment it's about 10 to 12 weeks
so that's extended out by the police
fitting process that we have so you know
we have about four or five weeks of
advertising and interviewing uh then we
have a police fitting process and they
can't start
um on at work until that police feelings
back and then we do the training and
then get them on onto poolside so it's
quite a long period
um our current staff only need to go
four weeks notice so there's a bit of a
gap in in that space so quite often we
are working two hour number or
below that and extra the staffer
required to do extra shifts
um and the average length of service for
a lifeguard's about 15 months is so we
bring them in quite young they're sort
of seniors at high school
um quite off often they go off to
University which gives them their 15
sort of month period that they're
staying with us
um
yeah
um and the range of services that we the
facility makeup is not in step with a
fast changing community so that would be
aging population
the changing spaces and the
rehabilitation side of
pools which which we don't have and
there is a
um not a lot of that in
um in invercargill I think the
hospital's got the rehabilitation pool
it's not utilized that well or open very
often and the other one is a Ruru school
which is the Special Needs school up in
the north end of town
um our fees and charges are already high
through the increases to these will
create a negative effect and reduce
participation
um as mentioned that before it's already
probably quite difficult for those on
their discretion expand is quite limited
already you know young people family
elderly so it's important that we can
try and keep those fees and charges as
um Community orientated as possible
uh and also there's increased costs of
products and contractors that we've seen
over
um
over a recent sort of 12 months with
covert and everything like that sort of
just increasing that
uh for Splash Palace uh our compliance
sits with uh pull safe accreditation so
that's a national recognized
accreditation that sits with
um Recreation aotearoa
um basically every 12 months we have
like a sort of like a peer review audit
done by another person in a facility in
New Zealand who's trained to to do this
maybe check our health and safety
systems our supervision guidelines our
processes and procedures
make sure our staffing numbers are
correct and they're all qualified
and we also have a duty to comply with
the NZ 5826 2010 which is our pool water
treatment standards and that one's
purely around the safety of our bathers
in the pool making sure that the pool is
treated properly and that there's no
excessive
um
chemicals in the pool that can do any
harm to someone
foreign
opportunities for cost savings
um we did an exercise in 2022 which
highlighted several different options to
reduce uh well provide cost savings
um that was to look at our products that
we utilize and see if we could find some
alternatives for a better price I'm sure
everyone's aware or heard of boc gases
increasing their CO2 prices quite
considerably we use CO2 in the treatment
of our water with the price tripled
so I went from about 30 odd thousand a
year to was going to hit up to 90 000 so
that prompted us to do some a bit more
research into what we were using in the
end we ended up finding another CO2
supplier that brought the cost Back Down
To What We were originally playing with
boc so brought it backwards and budget
so quite happy with that
um the improved efficiency in the lunar
swim school so we put into minimum class
levels we don't run classes if we don't
have enough numbers for them because it
was sort of costing us money so we've
implemented that already
and we've also implemented the change in
weekend operational hours
which went live in
May
which is
um been a successful change
in addition to those cost savings there
were some other opportunities to
increase Revenue that have also been
identified
um that was looking at progressing with
the least of a rental of a space to a
like an Allied Health or physiotherapist
type service
um that would complement the facility we
have a lot of physiotherapists using the
facility already so having them inside
our four walls sort of makes sense
and then just a continued improvement in
our commercial performance of the cafe
and Retail Services
um
and just on that you know that that has
done reasonably well and we look back at
our budget and now and and that when I
said before we took around about two
million dollars of Revenue six hundred
thousand dollars of that came from our
retail and Cafe space so that's if we
didn't have that
um
then obviously we'll be looking at a
higher rates take than what we would
have so it's really important that we
focus on these subsidiary services that
are still really found in aquatic
services to offset that rate stake okay
so what's the majority of that split
then Stephen between retail and Cafe is
the majority of it cafe or all retail
mostly Cafe
it's uh I think we did
around about a hundred and twenty 130 in
the retail and the rest was the cafe
thank you
um so proposals for new and lifted level
of services
um
alterations to changing rooms
to create some more private change
cubicles
the way
um the demand is or the change in the
trend of the use of the changing rooms
is changing within the community
so identifying
um or that basically the
um how we use them has changed and then
let's put more focus on our private
changing cubicles which is then we don't
have enough of those so we only have
five and the demand on that has
increased so therefore we have more
people waiting to get you access these
private changing cubicles so
um some pools these Renewables have put
in like Christchurch like a
uh changing Village which is all private
changing cubicles
so increasing the amount of private
change in cubicle space would be a um a
lifted level of service for us
and provide a better outcome for the
community and people using the facility
and obviously we have our new Pool
services that we've outlined in our ltp
strategic projects which consists of
Rehabilitation pool a smaller lap pool
Spar and cold pool so on Etc yep
and uh last slide measuring performance
so at the moment our kpis are just
measuring the number of visits per head
uh of the cargo City population
our user satisfaction survey is 85 or
more rate the overall quality is
satisfactory or above
time and a minimum for 25 meter public
lands are available swimming that kpi is
more aligned to the demand on the pool
with clubs and sports that want to
access it and what we can provide to our
public in terms of Lane swimming and
ecuading
uh times the capable uh with sorry
within operating guidelines of New
Zealand standards 5826 2010 which is the
poor water quality standards and we've
got a couple of new ones that we're
looking implementing a number of
unplanned pool closures there's
decreasing annually
um so unplanned pool closures
um
sort of people doing a frequency in the
pool and other bits and Bobs like that
yeah the infamous Code Brown Yeah the
code Browns
so
um we yeah anyway
um and we have draft Learners from
participation numbers are maintained or
increasing so we're just going to start
capturing that number on our learn to
swim
um
and hopefully try and increase it
and that's the last one any questions
Trish
um I've got a few
you said that you were hoping to make um
get revenue of 2.3 or 2.6 or reduced to
2.3 have you is this achievable
uh no as I said that
um
it would have to drop 2.3 would be 2.6
is probably not achievable in this stage
um unless we increase our participation
numbers and do some more work in that
space
2.3 sets it above our current level so
it gives us a Target to work to and it
gives us something for the team to sort
of drive and push themselves we don't
want a Target that's too easy for us we
want to challenge ourselves
a couple of questions about Staffing
am I right is it four months sort of
from the time you advertise to the time
they're actually trained to work in the
pool yeah 10 to 12 weeks yeah it's been
a long time isn't it yes
um
you know because I'm just thinking say
you lost two people in that time or
whatever you know you're sort of caught
because do you do any sort of forward
planning
um we have a sort of like a wee
partnership going with the YMCA where we
run you know three or four
um courses a year through the YMCA so
they run the whole they run the course
and we take sort of casual stuff from
that so we try and build up a casual
pool you'll notice that we had 15
casuals listed so we try and build up
that casual pool so that when we do need
staff yeah they're available and free to
come and Slot into those positions to
try and reduce that um that downtime or
that
um
that pressure on other staff to pick up
picture shifts and it probably is
important to know that through the last
two years we haven't had to close the
pool at all
um when we've had difficulties with
Staffing and that sort of stuff so the
team who actually really come to the
party they've picked up extra shifts and
and keep the place going for the
community do you actively engage with
the schools
um not at the stage no that is one of
our plans the YMCA does go around the
schools with their
through their courses and lots of stuff
I'm just thinking you know we could
match what the kids need and what you
need and also thinking about
um I'm sure you do this thinking about
back to um university you'll obviously
have a plan for anticipating that yes
yeah we have we have uh trends that we
know when sort of staff are going to be
coming and going so we can forward
think of that sort of thing you know
like you forecast the change quite a
logistical night yeah yeah thanks very
much anyways thanks thanks great yeah
thanks to you um just for us if they
want to acknowledge the sort of pressure
that you've been under with pool staff
around the sort of recent sort of
challenges around changing it's not an
easy process
I'm looking from the outside so I really
appreciate the work you've done and I
know you're intense to try and get a
resolution for everyone which is not
always easy so thank you
um a few questions
um
just had a bit of a scan of charges
we're actually
um cheaper for adopts and more expensive
for kids and families than Dunedin and
Queenstown so that's interesting when
we're trying to attract more rangatahi
um
so that's
that's you know something maybe for
affliction
um how many how many users annually
um so this furniture is just finished
we've
um just got 370 000 right okay yeah so
that's up from 240 000 the year before
um time frame for the change the
alterations to the changing rooms to get
a I think a set of a village a more of a
village taught yeah service
um I can't I can't give you a time frame
on that um is that in the next 12 months
though or well uh we'll have to work
with the property team on yeah but that
would be your intention obviously yes
okay
um top three costs
top three costs yeah Staffing 1.8
million yeah
um
then
um Power heating electricity that sort
of stuff it's about another six hundred
thousand dollars yeah
um and then it's just down to some any
other small operational costs
for me thank you Maria
um thank you um Stephen just firstly
um the comms that the pool sends out to
their clients has been really really
good it's quite it's always engaging
always support Focus so just want to say
that that's really good the other thing
I want to touch upon is the like
opportunities for future services to
offer of course that's going to cost
some initial money to do that but I was
wondering about I picked up about the
aqua therapy
um hydrotherapy poles and the fact that
you mentioned the hospitals has um
unsuitable hours is there like a future
plan to add more hydrotherapy services
to our pool like making
they're available so that it can be not
only just a Leisure activity it can also
be quite healing because those needs
around the southern south have been
identified that we just don't quite have
enough so there's a gap in our Market
um it's included in the plan in the on
the ltp Strategic project so it's not
looking at being delivered at the stage
till 29 30. yeah okay so that that's
with it so it's at home
okay
knobby then Tom then Peter yeah Steve a
couple of things um
you talked about the police vetting that
sometimes that's slowed the process down
from my understanding of two levels of
police vetting the normal one which
takes time you can fast track it but
there is an additional cost
so you wear the fast track
uh no I'm not
um we just do the police fitting that's
applies you can fast track at Social
Services fast track it but they pay
something like about fifty dollars to
get a fast track
um so I just thought I'd signal that
with you because if you have an urgent
need you can get the police feeling
because that tends to hold things up as
well
um the other issue is the issue of fees
and charges
um I guess you don't want to hear what
I'm about to say which is actually
reducing your income but it do we do we
going forward do we need to have some
ability to
um
Target
more cost effective service this is for
people that might be on community cards
Community ads or around the budgery
services or might have a health referral
do we have that capacity now is it
something yeah income but I mean yeah no
we're currently doing it at the moment
like we offer community service
discounts of I think it's 25 and with
um
doctors referring people to the poor we
have a green green prescription that we
were part of okay oh yeah thank you I
guess the last question for me was
something that uh Trish writes as well I
think oh no Grant races as well which is
the private change rooms not many of
those in the middle cluster
when you say you've got to talk to uh
um
to our team about
property thinking about doing it it
doesn't really fit with the current
current building does it
look there's no real capacity to put
another 10 or 15 in there is there
unless it's a major scale internal
Redevelopment which may affect some
um walls now I'd have to go external to
the building current building yep thank
you
Tom
so I think of what you said the the main
concern I would hope would be about the
transfer of
course from users to rate pairs people
have still got to pay for it of course
when I look at the gap between required
revenue and what you expect to get the
gap's about 10 or so
if I look then at the use of charges
um 10 would be less than a dollar extra
for each of them
so my question would be whether what
evidence you would have that somebody
who pays seven dollars with no pay 7.50
for example whether that would actually
stop them from coming to the pool
it has in the past when we've increased
our fees and charges being an issue for
some people
that though they feel that they're
double paying as well with the rates and
the
and the entry costs
thank you
Peter
um we're catering for the Aging
population down there at the poll
um Southland hospital at Q hospital do
have their own pool and a lot of elderly
people go there also are we competing
against the hospital are they competing
with us
No I
um
I feel that the hospital pool from what
I understand and I've been involved with
their pool
um over the last 18 years now and then
is that quite often they have issues and
it's not open to anyone else outside of
the rehabilitation services that they
provide so it's not open to public or
anything like that
it's very limited from what I understand
thank you that's great that's right
Leslie
thanks Mr chair Stephen
do we as Paul's have a relationship with
ACC I ask because I've noticed an
increasing trend for ACC claimants to
need pool passes as part of
Rehabilitation and I'm just wondering if
we've ever thought about
a special price to encourage that
um I'm not sure if our relationships
that's directly with ACC that's more the
provider of the the like the physio or
the doctors but we have plenty of
physiotherapists that come in for
rehabilitational services which I'm sure
there'll be an ACC component to that
yeah
yeah it's the
been ever have you ever had feedback
that there's a bit of a um
Bay Area
in the price of our pool passes for that
category
no not as far as I'm aware now okay okay
thanks
thank you any more questions
probably just just a final and not
really a question but just to follow on
from Tom's suggestion that
um moving an entry fee 10
I guess we're hearing from Stephen that
puts up a bit of a barrier initially but
I think that tends to Plateau out our
foot on I mean when I look at the the
big picture for Council I see us putting
best part of 700 000 into a stadium
um more than a million into a library I
guess that we we fund through rates as
opposed to user pay
um
and I just wonder whether we've got the
balance right you know do we provide
given the health benefits of being
active and stuff like whether we've got
that balance right where they're
somewhere online we need to look at
whether we have a more of a shift
towards um rates as opposed to user base
yeah I think you're right it is a
balancing act in that if you
subsidized for high needs low-income
areas a little more you can get your
numbers up and boost your income that
way the other question I guess that we
face as governance and what Stephen's
putting to us is our contribution rates
contributions 900
000 roughly per annum at the moment
Stephen uh yes that's for this financial
year it wasn't that last Financial year
but we also had periods of closure
during lockdown as well in the previous
two years I guess the other the thing is
though do we sorry I've just finished
the do we increase the amount of what we
call public good yeah do we update we
believe that our interest is making sure
that uh healthy activity is accessible
for for all our residents and that's
something that I think we can consider
through the ltp process I think the
other side of the equation of course is
if it becomes too popular because you're
reducing the user pay component then
Steve might have more demanded he can
cope with
so I don't think we'd subsidize the
likes of hydro slime
[Laughter]
but you know mind you if you run up that
those stairs often enough and get your
hat right up Michael
thank you through yourself to you I just
want to remind councilors when they're
looking at the user pay scenario they
are only looking at the service
components with um all of our facilities
that we we provide a service within the
the facility itself is actually with no
service being provided is actually rates
funded so the building itself was
provided by the council but then the
service is then applied on top and then
and the the user equation that you look
at is about that service that's a
fundamental Choice that's been made by
Council in the past around all of it all
of the facilities and we continue to
operate in that manner so the split
you're hearing is in relation to the
service that's happening within the
facility just want to be clear on that
yeah just while we examine the subject
of services Stephen I'll throw in the
the thorny uh question that's plagued us
a couple of times in the past do you
believe as manager that there is
potentially sufficient demand for
on-site gym services
can you please repeat that do you
believe that there is demand for on-site
gym services
yes
um I believe there is but however
there's gyms popping up left right and
center around town and you would have to
change the focus to be a gym swim access
only so if you're a member of the pool
you'd be a member of the gym something
that another gym service doesn't provide
um
calls it generally have gyms
um do reasonably well in terms of their
revenue to rates ratios
thanks yeah I think it's one of those
balancing acts when we have to be
careful about how we compete against the
private sector but it was something that
was raised with us a couple of years ago
councilors any other questions Leslie
just because you've raised that one Mr
chair if it came down to it Stephen
you would prefer an on-site physio
possibility over
an on-site gym
the on-site physio
we have sort of their capability to
provide their now in this in space
inside the facility
um a gym would be something that we you
know that I would like although I would
not want to operate it because I'm not a
gym person as we can clearly tell
um
but
I think that's something that we could
look at you know if we if counselor
wanted to
um at the in their ltp strategic
projects that the on-site physio would
be a much easier thing to put in place
because basically the facility can cope
with it it's very little adjustment
thanks thanks
okay thanks Stephen always good to hear
from another fellow bodybuilder thank
you
we should build another Direction
sometimes I appreciate that and
councilors thank you for the questions
um
Caroline and Chris thank you for
arriving early because that's uh
fortuitous if you want to come up and
take a seat and take us through parks
do you want to pull that mic around
please Carl I can do yeah so um
good morning Caroline rain on the parks
my creation manager and with me is Chris
Bowen who's a strategic advisor for the
recreation setting
um
what you've we've done a probably a
similar presentation to those that
you've seen come before you uh
Dana we haven't got this right yet how
do we go next slide
we've got a thing
that Chris has got next
so in the overview of our activity what
you've got is a very comprehensive
um open and Recreation spaces activity
which we're obviously providing for our
residents International domestic sources
to connect with
um I'm not going to read through the
slides you can see we've got a
comprehensive set of reserves there
we've got over 160 reserves and multiple
Civic spaces that our team
um
provide careful look after
135 individual rectangular Sports fields
and that's over 3 000 hectares of Green
Space
and we obviously provide the essential
Services the cemetery and crematorium
for our
um population for our community and as a
park as a Lawn Cemetery that's about the
same size as Queen's Park so we've got
some pretty sizable spaces to look after
in our environmental program we are
looking after lots of different
environmental reserves and also a
captive breeding program obviously the
Tuatara come um
come to the floor quite often but we've
got Kaka and Kia which we manage in
partnership with Doc and other sites
around the southern south island
foreign
ties and our community outcomes are um
obviously Leisure and Recreation we are
putting people at the heart of
everything that we do but we're also in
a continuous Improvement cycle
we are looking to navigate climate
change we do that through mainly through
our management plans and our Master
plans so you've seen coming up at the
moment the Sandy Point master plan will
be the next one coming up towards you
and also you know meeting our people's
diverse cultural needs we are looking
mainly to provide user satisfaction
that's a primary driver so it's people
again
um and future Focus that's that
continuous Improvement cycle we are
trying to become economically
sustainable we've got a huge
sustainability focus in the equipment
that we use across the parks and also
looking at targeting our resourcing in
different ways in Partnerships and
Innovations
and so that we can manage infrastructure
for as long as we can
um assessment Improvement Works been
coming on very very well over the last
six seven months
um predominantly with the arrival of
crestos here so
um that's aligning our operational
delivery and our opportunities but with
the community keeps changing and making
sure that we can meet those needs that
system improvement work we'll talk a
little bit later on
foreign
budget looking at just over 10 million
for the service for the activity
um significant amount of capital some of
that is
um based on new programs coming through
like the bluff motuhe activity Precinct
so some of that Capital sitting in that
generally speaking we have on average
470 000 for our annual Capital renewals
which we mainly do to ensure that the
health and safety of our assets are well
managed
79 people in the team
going around 80 at all times
and we maintain the level of service
through that budget
and three primary teams operation
delivery which is our functional teams
performance which is more environmental
teams and also the small projects and
business support
and then obviously the planning and
strategic advice that operational
delivery team is 53 FTA the performance
team is 21 and the planning and
strategic advice is for
thank you
we are progressively moving our levels
of service to align with national
standards such as Recreation aotearoa
and that's what we're aiming to do over
the next three years to ensure that
we've actually got a very clear Baseline
and that we can measure ourselves
against that Baseline so that you can
see where we're achieving
um obviously basing that on our industry
standards and then that'll enable us to
prioritize where we
um where we work
it is currently costing more to
maintainer levels of service so we are
looking at that prioritization in the
future to see where we actually need to
work more for different users and
obviously there's there may be some
misalignment that will be able to manage
better once we've got those core
national standards really
um embedded in the service
and we'll be able to show you exactly
where we're achieving and where we're
not achieving
oh thanks Caroline uh if you would have
noticed on a previous slide uh
operational budget is a 70 30 split uh
so 70 rates funded and 30 is through
Revenue we're always looking for ways to
become more efficient and through cost
savings to try and ensure that we're
getting a best bang for our buck uh and
so there's a couple of different
strategies here to address that cost
saving one of them is to increase our
Revenue Target our annual revenue coming
in
um we've done this in a couple of ways
we're proposing to do this in a couple
of ways one's through we've got a new
forestry management provider
um which will be able to incrementally
increase our Revenue uh increase that to
serve around 100K over the next three to
five years that new provider is also
multi-disciplined so they're not just
forestry contractor they're bringing in
other components that are related to the
industry like carbon sequestation and
other manners in which we can generate a
bit of revenue from our parks and
Reserves we also have a integrated
booking system coming on coming live
over the next couple of months and what
that'll give us the ability to do is
actually have a really good demand
assessment so we can strategically
assess what our user fees and charges
should be
um
another aspect that we're looking at at
the moment is um The Prompt payment
discount that we give for our Funeral
Directors this is to be Revisited over
the next few years based on on
submissions so that's one strategy
around increasing Revenue coming into
Council
um decreasing levels of service so this
is around adjusting our levels of
service based on our user needs at the
moment uh the standards that we work to
in-house standards and we'll talk to
that a bit more moving forward but
adjusting these levels of service so
that they're targeted for our user can
potentially reduce the costs
um you'll have seen this through the
Lomo approach that we're trialling in
locations
such as Talbot Street Reserve and out at
Sandy Point you'll see that when we
reduce the mowing it doesn't have a
significant impact on our users and so
it is about trying to be more efficient
with our costs that we have and that
will as you will see have um
changing levels of service one of the
other targets that we've got here is
around potential land disposal and so
this will bring on when they go through
that process one-off cash injection but
also um there is a slight reduction in
maintenance cost however that is that
it's slight
so when we're looking at those proposals
for newer lifted levels of service those
alignments are nationally
um National and Regional standards also
align with things such as the regional
spaces and places work that we're doing
um
we're going to be transitioning over the
next few years to these
um new standards as I said so you know
for example we're going to be making
sure that we actually cover the New
Zealand track and structure handbook is
something that we adhere to but we'll
also be able to tell you to what
standard we adhere to where
um because at the moment we might look
at 100 everywhere and that might not be
the what the users in everywhere needs
so it'll enable us to again again come
back to you with those baselines and let
you know where we're at on each of these
different areas
um it
I was going to move over to Chris on
this point so one of the things Caroline
uh so one of the aspects that we do need
to um do better on in this regard is is
the data that we are collecting and
we're monitoring and so over the next
three years we're looking at collecting
a whole lot more data not only on our
maintenance and category of which our
parks are being maintained too but also
what is our community's expectations of
these Parks so we can actually align to
our community user or Community needs
sorry call them user needs normally and
so at the moment the standards which we
deliver are very good standards and
across the board we do very well when
considering council's reputational risk
so it's that health and safety component
that's our primary drive what we're
looking to bring in is more around the
experience design and what is that user
need so it's just increasing the level
of maturity and in the standards that we
deliver for our Council
Maybe
and this moves on to opportunities for
Council to consider so there's a few
slides here
um the first couple are around what the
council's doing and then we move into
what we're doing in Partnership uh and
so I'm just going to go through these
bit by bit
um for the Eastern Cemetery groundwater
management we have a significant issue
that we have at our Eastern cemeteries
at the moment with the water table at
this time of year is unacceptably high
and so that means that the experience or
the level of service that we're
providing are the users for that
facility is unacceptable and so we're
working design work is currently
underway to understand what that's going
to cost to rectify that situation but
that's a high priority for parks and rec
in the coming years
we also have the opportunity to better
develop our sculpture walk around our
CBD and our urban city Urban space
um
we've done an assessment of what's there
already thinking about from the animal
park side of Queens Park going down to
the umbrella moving through the CBD
motorcycle Mecca
otapuni Gardens and then background of
the cenotaph to Queen's Park in the new
Museum facility we've identified 10
locations where there's probably more
than five minutes walk where you don't
interact with something whether that be
a mural but a history or a sculpture and
so this investment over the next 10
years will will create quite a
substantial visitor experience
uh Turtle Thompson Sports field is
something that was raised to me when I
first started around having visitor
safety concerns at this site
um what we've done that was identified
through the last long-term planning
process I've run a couple of sessions
one was stakeholders and one with
Neighbors at Timber Thompson Park itself
that that problem statement really is
being identified around
moving Vehicles rather than vehicle
capacity and so we're working closely
with our infrastructure team in roading
and also wakakotahi looking at different
options one of those options the primary
options looks to be pushing out onto a
state highway one there to create a
one-way flow around the the core problem
there on Islington Street
oh to support the um New facility
project 1225 there's also integrated
landscape design here for Queen's Park
so the pmo 10 project management office
are doing a fantastic job of delivering
a new Museum a new facility that's
fantastic Parks and Recreation are
really Keen to make sure that it sits
really well within the environment how
it connects through to the um to the
Rose Garden how it connects through to
the Tuatara facility and so there's a
option here for the council to consider
that that landscape design around that
new facility
um and also I wanted to put a flag up
here for implementing the Sandy Point
master plan I know the dollar figures
they're a vacant but we're almost at the
end of the master plan we're currently
um about to go and revisit to those that
submitted uh on the on the draft master
plan to show them what we heard that
they said and then we're going to come
back to council and show the the um the
master plan in its final state
uh and so those are the couple of slides
that the council are doing but I thought
I'd put a couple of slides in with
regards to um what we're doing in
Partnership
um we've got uh
presentation sorry we've got a project
that's been submitted to us from the
leasi of the lake Hawkins Reserve Lake
Hawkins is the reserve that's in front
of the airport between the Steve Street
Stock bank and the airport and our
management plan is to actually
transition that back to a Scenic reserve
and that's been uh very challenging for
Council the currently see has put in a
project plan of a 20-year plan to
rejuvenate that Reserve while continuing
to lease the land for grazing sheep and
so that proposal that we've put forward
um we're working with the airport we're
working with the leasi we're working
with the commissioner doc on how to
invest in that but for a very small
investment from Council we'd get a
significant biodiversity increase in
that Reserve
and one of the other
um projects that we're working in
Partnership that's just starting right
now through the transport package in
wakakotahi uh we've been able to Source
a 100K for a new pump track to be based
uh in South City uh and so
um that was through our infrastructure
team putting a bid forward through the
wakakotahi at that site there's also a
community garden proposed at the back of
the awarua oh sorry back of the Aurora
College
um sorry apologies yeah you're fine so I
just suppose
apologies
so what we're talking about here is a
minor investment around
redesigning newbie Street Reserve will
actually activate a fair amount of work
uh at the back of that Aurora College
Ministry of Education land so it's just
starting at the moment but I just wanted
to make sure that the council were
across a couple of these projects that
are coming up
one of the things I really wanted to
talk about was around our kpis
just
um gonna lead into Chris talking about
this by saying obviously with the the
different changes of service will also
mean that we will change our kpis in the
next
um ltp and actually moving these kpis to
be come
less of a provider model so we've done a
lot of our kpis at the moment about
provision of something and moving
towards what our users need and what our
community wants so the kpis that we're
proposing going forward are going to be
aimed in that area
um more specifically I'll let Chris talk
so uh thanks Caroline we've kept the
qualitative kpis in here around what is
our community how do they feel what do
they think about what we're doing we've
also brought in um well we've expanded
the existing Partnerships one to include
how many mous do we have with our
community to actually register how well
we're doing
at the moment the provision of assets
kpis
looks something like how many areas do
we mow per population
and that's not that good at telling a
story
um and so what we are proposing is over
the next three years that we develop
additional kpis based on those visitor
experiences so how many sports Fields
have to standard whatever percentage of
our tracks to standard or a bold one
that we'd like to put forward is what
percentage of our environmental reserves
are to standard and so that would take
quite a bit of work to develop those but
we're proposing that we do those over
the next three years but shifting our
kpis from Asic provision to user
satisfaction is really critical in this
space
foreign
there so obviously um
Parks and Recreation is quite an asset
Rich area
um but our planning is all around those
national standards
um making sure that we've got uh our
space remains as good as it is or we're
improving it for future years
um and that conditioned summary that
we've got and actually being able to
put more of a emphasis on those renewals
for our programs it's going to show us
in the future what we really need in
this area so that planning is all going
to be based on the standards that we've
got in the inspection to standards which
going back to the
um how we run our service we've got the
performance team that actually look at
our provision for us to enable us to
stay to standard or know where we are in
that area
so that Improvement and that I think
you've heard a lot about what we're
planning on doing over the next three
years is improving our
um data capture and our ability to tell
that story better than we currently do
and that's going to be seen throughout
the activity plan and then through those
asset plans
that would be my last slide or our last
slide I'm sure you may have some
questions for us
can I just kick off with two questions
one's around the
um levels of service
Baseline looking at the standards set by
recreational
um how many of our neighboring Tas use
that as well oh gosh I couldn't it's
fairly I couldn't give you a number but
it's fairly consistent across the
country recreational Toyota standards
are adopted by many councils such as
the new Plymouth city council and
Christchurch city council or two that
I've been working with and they are
adopted if not in part also fully so
there's a categorization system within
those recreational Toyota standards that
provide different levels of service so
it doesn't tie us to anything we can
choose whether we provide a basic a
standard or a premium within those
categories it's just a framework that
gives us the ability to to organize our
work great thanks Chris just when you
were talking about the eastern Cemetery
as well and the issues with groundwater
how does that compare you to the pest
problem that we have during the sunnier
period of the year
um our I suppose our pest
um pest animals are about to go out to
Tender to make sure that we've got
really good contractors managing that
area
um we
yeah that's probably the best answer I
can give you there we're about to tend
to that work to make sure that it's it
improves on what we've currently got
councilman's life thanks Caroline
councilors Tom
so two questions maybe the First
Response want to comment on the question
but it doesn't seem to me that as we
listen the officers speak about a whole
range of things you know there are there
are new standards and there are you know
new things being issued nationally that
require us to
um the the impact of all of those things
I think if we did everything would be
you know an extraordinary increase in
rates and and therefore I think you know
discipline
would really need to be that every time
we start something you look at what
we're going to start to kind of balance
it I mean I think that's pragmatically
what we what we're going to have to do
but but my question is about a different
thing so
um the extensive watch parks and
reserves mitigate carbon
um Plus in terms of you know an existing
parks and reserves
um but also with the future potential
for that might be and and whether that
can be used as an offset for council's
only missions and indeed where that
actually we might be able to earn some
money for it if we if we do it smartly
so my question is really about the
extent to which we are thinking about
that and normally I'm sure everybody's
thinking about it but we actually did
any work at the moment to again
projector yeah we that's where at the
start of that Journey councilor Campbell
that's something that we absolutely want
to be able to do we do absolutely want
to be able to measure the carbon across
our parks and Reserves Network so that
we've got a way better understanding
than we currently have and the forestry
contractors that we've actually engaged
with have got that capability so we're
at the start of their contract but that
is it's definitely a goal of ours over
the next three years to really measure
that well
uh Grant been knobby Leslie and Ria
thanks to you um firstly I really like
the thought of the um Aurora project
with the pump track how was that site
chosen versus other areas in Seattle
City
uh I'm unaware so that was put forward
by our infrastructure team it's right at
the start of the
um project and so we've got a meeting
with the college and wakatahi and our
infrastructure in the next couple of
weeks uh to kick that off so and is the
funding tag to that site always like a
week if there's a better site that
became oh that's what we need to look
into cancer remedy it came through the
transport choices package so it was
something that came and was offered
through Thai so we don't know at this
stage we we've just been asked because
of Parks and Recreation and we've
already done pump tracks it's something
it's part of the project that we're
being asked to look at to deliver so the
location is something that we can
um review and see where you know what
flexibility we have we don't currently
know yeah I think it'd be great to see
the community of South City engaged
around that I mean
there's obviously some benefits and with
the mobile one that's going around at
prison but I think the big good to do
that yeah um of the 3000 hectares What
proportion of that is Sandy Point and is
the forestry included in that so is that
is it the full sum of Sandy Point yeah
all of Sunday point is part so that's
three thousand hectares is all of the
reserves that we manage across yeah so
there's a portion in there that would be
classified as commercial isn't it it's a
portion of its forestry yeah yeah okay
what potential is there for
um rationalization of that 3000 hit this
I think you mentioned but the land
disposal proposal that we saw yeah so
what roughly in terms of hectares are
you talking
um so it would
the
land disposal process that land is
coming to the CWC next is indicating the
process to start and so the first step
of that process is public consultation
yeah um and so we have identified some
sections of land
um the the total amount uh will be
determined after through that public
quantity so but at the moment what what
sort of areas
how much we don't have that uh to have
that data so you've given consideration
to some blocks or might be sober you're
not aware of how much that is
so we can come we can come back to you
with that but that's not on the top of
my head okay
um
here I'm sort of similar to the thinking
of time around you know that it seems to
be as regulatory approach to Parks which
if I'm Frank worries me a little bit I
understand the importance of things like
self and safety and net but you know
that can't be offset against just
functionality and Pregnant pragmatism
around
um you know
the use of friendliness of it versus
um you know the cost and if you look at
say phosphine apart that Loop track
there right now you could go and upgrade
that and put metal all around it and
spend you know and bury off every sort
of we fall off and those sorts of things
or just put a song up and say this is a
draw with a track only so that's why we
sort of we and those standards are going
to be based on user satisfaction what
the user wants at sites that's
absolutely what we're going to be doing
making sure that the sites that we've
got meet what our community want yeah so
yeah so I think we can use sort of
regulatory standards and National
standards as a sort of a overall arching
framework but we have to be very
pragmatic because otherwise national
standards just linked to more cost
absolutely absolutely can I um feed into
that please and just say it doesn't
necessarily change the standard that
we're delivering so it just gives us a
framework to deliver within those
standards and the easiest way for me to
explain that is to say every category in
recreationality has a premium of
standard and a basic version of that
category so whether we're investing the
same or more or less is all within that
framework so just because we're adopting
these industry standards doesn't
necessarily mean that we're going to
increase the investment so if the
community expectation was below the base
extended what would the parks team do we
would do what the community wanted good
and then just finally um and the master
plan for Sandy Point Security
cameras those sorts of things is that
part of that plan that might become part
of the management plan so the the master
plan is more of the overarching view of
what we do at that site over the next 30
to 50 years the detail of how we deliver
that will come in the management plan
stage so when will that management plan
be swiftly following in the like matter
of months after the master plan's been
adopted so when's the master plan come
true
of the year was the last report you
brought to community well-being okay
because I mean I've had lots of feedback
and I know you know young families and
females in particular that won't go to
Sandy Point because they feel unsafe you
know if I talk to you know the police
they are aware that this criminal
activity that happens out there you know
with cameras on these so I think that
makes them really we installed a camera
out there um less than 12 months ago
yeah just on the corner of the year yeah
I like where it is
knobby yeah um a lot of good things to
like about what we we just heard but
I've got some a couple of videos that
I'm still been uneasy there one is the
ability of parks and Reserve to do
traffic management
um so that's an ongoing saw for me it
has been for years about our inability
to be able to respond to the I guess the
beautification of the inner city that
you can't just go and run some cones out
tomorrow and decide to tidy up the
center plots you've got to have this
traffic management plan and an
independent set of
um uh providers that come and put the
codes out and then manage the traffic
warn you weed the guns and it just seems
to me over a period of time we've got
around that by putting
um Evergreens in the middle plots that
don't look all that nice compared to
some places and so that's and I know the
Dynamics of needing to be able to
um train somebody up to be able to do
that traffic management and the moment
you train and Lake after downers or
somewhere else because they get better
money there but it's still on the Shelf
that needs to be looked at in a good
examples
there's been some militias odatara in
the last week or two about people
picking up rubbish out there so again
with plastic beer and they go down but
they get advice from Council so they say
they get a license from Council went to
presumers regulatory or parks and
reserves to say hey you can't just
wander down the Main Street picking up
rubbish and so that's a catch-22
situation again so
um I'm not sure how you get past that
but it's just something it continues to
be there
um picking up on what Grant said about
the Aurora College project that would
worry me if we were going away because I
think yeah preferred site would be
Russell Square itself so we're doing a
lot of work in South City and hopefully
we'll do more work to bring a community
Hub back into this that Central Area
um I think between where the current
playground is in Russell Square you go
across the road there's a vacant piece
of land and then there's two dog
enclosures and that vacant piece of land
you could fit well today at the moment
and the worry for going to Aurora
college is that the what we found in the
otatara model is that most the people
that actually go and use it are younger
children which is what we wanted
um given that cell said he's got the BMX
track which is huge and it gets the
teenagers we found that although the
sort of secondary school kids used the
track periodically if that's died away
and if you look there now it's not a
something you do after school people
going into the weekends and buying days
and they've take very young children and
they go on the track I've seen very few
um what you call teenagers here now the
initial Novelties worn off so I think
that's what Grant was alluding to
whether we've got alternative sites and
whether the funding is secured would be
open to a site change as opposed to it's
conditional to going to newbie Street or
wherever it is I can't visualize newbie
streaming but if it's up on that close
to Aurora I think you'd be taking away
some of the um potential to have it in
the inner city in the South City which
is where we're encouraging people to
come families to come for the park for
the dog area for the community Hub
that's starting to get get some traction
and the shopping it just puts it all in
one package if you have them way up in
that cell whatever it is south east
corner
um when you isolate one of the issues
with the isolation is the issue of
teenagers and drugs and
how they go to the toilet and lots of
other things which was initial
concerning over time but that's died
away so just I'll get some playing in it
and the last thing to flag is the
terminal Thompson Sports area I mean
it's just an absolute disaster we're
just not of your making but we
desperately need to resolve that
um I know the steps and I get is that
the only sport at the moment that's
gotten growth in the
um sort of six to 14 year olds is soft
football
and then they'll surprise you I won't
surprise your car on that's right um but
I go to any most weekends to see a
grandson play and I can tell you the
parking is just absolutely diabolical
it's a and over and above the people
parking on the grass which just makes a
mess for you guys as well you've also
got the issue of children trying to get
into cars post games because the games
just go on and getting out onto Isabella
on to Linda Farm as a nightmare as well
um but the parking's an issue and I
don't understand why we don't if you can
visualize when you go in there and you
do the loop and you come back out
between the loop and where the fencing
is or the for the main pitch that's what
the proposal was coming out onto State
Highway one there yep yep yep no but
what I'm saying for the parking
if you go where the Loopers you go
around you walk up a slight Hill until
you get to the astro turf why don't we
come to that and take it right down to
the first house in the street because
that none of that's used it just slips
in vacant if we tar sealed that in there
we double the size of the parking now
those Acosta there but at the moment
it's just an excellent waiting to happen
taking young kids back and for those
cars there's cars all outside and it's
just a capacity room isn't there also a
risk knobby of damage to cars there
though because we all see a fair number
of balls go over that
fences people should have gone I don't
think this I mean like I'm 40 years down
here I don't think the soccer balls
damaged the cars people are smart enough
to know that if if you're going to if
there was a car park there and you're a
bit worried about windscreen wipers you
just get back into a space as opposed to
putting it towards it I was thinking
about windscreen wipers those the ball
is coming down from a great height and
if it hits you if you're getting it I
didn't if you if you're back then it
wouldn't be a problem but when you when
you go back into that lower area
so there's a bit of a wooden fence that
runs along so you've got the piece I'm
talking about there's actually talking
down towards the residences more Yep
that piece to the residence down the
bottom there is not used there are
soccer pictures further in yep but that
front piece we could double the size
right now I did some quick mess the
other day
but if you've ever been here you'll know
what I'm talking about
yeah it's good that those posts have
gone and that stop the um the Lazy
Afternoon players from going and parking
up right next to the ground yeah
but I guess either so some of the site
investigation we've done there
um mayor Clark is there's a lot of
underground services through that area
which would
greatly increase the cost of putting car
parking there well that that's if you
carve into it so if you've got land that
looks like that you can take this piece
off
and flatten it out then you're into what
exactly saying but if you top up the
other end that way a little bit people
will park on the side but if it's not
too steep
I don't know what you're saying um and
as a final for me I'm really pleased
that you've picked up on a couple of
areas of quite passionate about The
Walking Urban walking is great one of
the issues for me will be uplighting if
you go around oh it's definitely
encouraging and um and I think you're
quite right it's not something we do in
one head we might just um do it in
stages yeah might do
otapuni first and then
some sculptures and which makes it more
manageable yeah so thanks man I'm buying
the other response to your comments sure
around
um
uh what you were saying about uh
tamariki and rangatahi at pump tracks
and at their MX tracks and so one of the
locations that we're looking to review
at the moment uh is after Southland BMX
have completed their fantastic project
at Elizabeth Park is to actually do a
bit of a review of Elizabeth Park how
can we maximize that space so I
understand what you're saying Nobby uh
with regards to langatahi and tamariki
requiring different Services
um and so that that's not lost on us we
are aware of that I guess the response
to that is if I look at Alexandra
that's I've got a BMX track a very basic
track for kids to learn how to do the
traffic lights and then next to it
they've got the one with a skateboarding
there is still some unease there that
when you start mixing six-year-olds with
17 18 19 year olds you introduce
different social issues and that's why I
think the one over targets worked out
well because the old ones are not going
there much anymore
sorry
yeah yeah so I mean but that's still an
issue that I've asked people in
Alexander how they felt about
because the BMX tends to be an older I
mean you don't get the six-year-old
riding a BMX track whatever tried but
they don't so
the beauty of the pump track being by
itself is a parent to take them there
and they know that there's nothing else
that might put them at risk I guess
older kids drug use stuff like that
stand over tactics in some places
certainly in Alex there's that
thank you okay here's the speaking order
I've got currently Leslie rear pania
then Alex Leslie thank you
um
some symmetry water table I've had a lot
of feedback about the problem yeah
um you know from people who have been
quite upset really yeah um so it's
really good to hear it's been addressed
so you think it'll be something that can
be addressed this
year what I currently we've engaged upon
us who have a couple of subbies in as
well and so
start of
sorry middle of August for that project
plan is when their design will come
through and what we'll be able to do
from that design is cost
so we'll pick a request for a quote to
understand what that design will cost to
implement so
won't be able to answer that question
until that time frame when the Design's
finished that's good to know the timings
like getting the costs that's great
um the Newbie Street issue I've got a
slightly different take as a resident of
South invercargill I went to the launch
of the community garden in that big
space behind Aurora college and I did
think at the time that it would be the
opportunity to upgrade our newbie Street
playground more than somewhat in Synergy
with that project because that's going
to be a huge community garden a lot of
community involvement for those who
don't know the area that's quite a
distance from Aurora College because
you're looking at Aurora
space for the community garden in Ruby
Street yeah
um so while I'm open to looking at other
sites
in South invercargill I do think there's
a lot of synergy with developing newbie
street is a very busy part of the South
invercargill area
um
and it might well be worth since we've
got the pump check that's movable doing
quite a bit of testing
before the final decision comes
um the other one I just want to say
thank you for Elizabeth Park I was going
to raise that
um again as a South invercargill
resident I've long thought we could do
quite a bit more to maximize Elizabeth
Park
it's a it's a great Park it's a huge
area lots of potential for really
getting improvements in there and I know
there are some yeah that are a bit of a
challenge but unreally supportive of
looking at a plan for what we can do to
maximize that area so thanks for that I
was going to raise it so I was really
pleased that you mentioned it first to
respond to your newbie Street comment
that project approached Council because
they were requesting vehicle access
across Ubisoft yes and so right away
access process will be will be
undertaken when that project gets
underway
um and so what that means for that site
is there will need to be a redesign of
of where the play equipment is and so uh
we're going to separate out the pump
track conversation and just talk about
the
um the murder the community garden there
um actually the functionality of having
a right-of-way access across one of our
reserves to enable that project to
succeed will require a redesign of
newbie Street playground I cut sorry
Reserve we noticed that at the launch
that
quite a large number of people at the
launch just getting across the reserve
was a very muddy exercises
it's not what our users want not what
our community wants yeah
um thank you I just wanted to touch on a
couple of things really the
um slide that showed the uh
I guess the opportunity for future
funding streams and to deal with the
funeral directors prompt payment
discount I recall that we'd had a
discussion around this table
I don't know a few months ago talking
about that and I haven't quite and I
don't quite understand exactly if you
could just clarify for me so it's taken
away the funeral directors from
administrating that fee and as a council
taking that role on and therefore
there's where the savings are or is it
something
so the um when we propose at the moment
the funeral director has got a prompt
payment discount yeah um if we remove
that they've indicated that they would
wish us to then pick up the service of
um charging their
Community yeah so that that would be the
costs that we we need to actually do a
cost benefit analysis to understand
whether the cost savings that we would
make would actually match that and
that's what we're about to do okay so
that's why I was interested like there
was a hundred thousand dollars I think I
saw it they're going to say where does
that come from that that's only for
correct payers the answer to your
question so the question that Council
faces is do does the council subsidize
those businesses which is what we're
currently doing yeah but we need to then
work out whether if we bring that
service in-house how much that then
would cost us to deliver and that's the
piece of work we're currently doing yeah
yeah and it's good the other thing too
is that you mentioned about the um
sculptures and murals and potential and
walking
um art groups or what have you
I noticed that there isn't a mentality
in the cars minutes away and so how are
we going to make sure that we are
connected to our South City area
um along with those types of
Society um is developing uh Trails
through like South alive for developing
Heritage Trail as an example uh and
actually that's not too far for Stones
Throw from where otoponia is and so it's
important that we maximize uh our
recreational opportunities across our
city and so we need to make sure that
those things are integrated and not
stand in isolation
uh
sorry yep
um just in regards to the kpis I you
know in changing that I think it's
really good in in the sense that
quantitative data doesn't always tell
the story and so um just wondering are
you looking at using results-based
accountability type framework or
something similar to that that actually
really looks at communities whanau and
consumer leads so it might be something
to consider as well yeah
um the other thing is I just want to
touch on a grant or already sort of hit
the nail on the head around the Sandy
Point plan and security because yeah
I've had and I live in Bluff but I still
have people sort of note that
um and just in supporter I've got mere
um Nobby just said in regards to Russell
Square because that's this came up on
Sunday at a consultation very but at
NoHo however around the rest of the
square and that the playground is
limited so you know in across the road
there's that Reserve there it could be
something developed for older children
and so that that was really highlighted
along with having actually a toilet
yeah it's very very recent yeah yeah so
so
um very positive they at this one area
one place that they all related to
that's great thank you for the feedback
yeah thanks yeah
oh that's me
um
I've got four questions sorry so this
might be your boyfriend of a Time drag
but um I just want you to touch on the
integrated booking system that you're
looking at launching
um can you tell me a little bit about
what that user experience will look like
and what services will be available it's
uh it's basically putting what we've
currently got our booking system is very
very manual yeah
um to fill out like yeah fill out forms
so it will be a web-based system which
will be really
um just very interactive very easy to
use yeah um it's just in the very early
stages so I can't tell you what the
picture looks like but it's we've got um
you'll know exactly what you're booking
and how long for and what you'll get for
it and what you need to do to provide
yeah so if I'm enjoy blogs and I want to
book the tennis courts beside the museum
or you know like any of our facilities
the band rotunda do I need power all of
those sorts of things you'll be able to
just you'll just go through and tick the
boxes I need one of those one of those
and one of those cool
um does the will it be like identify
different types of use that will be
permitted with each yeah so it will
raise Flags so if there's certain things
that you can or can't do in a certain
place the booking form itself will
um either let you agree that you're
going to be doing something and go like
taking the I agree box or um or just say
yeah it's got a lot of that information
within it yet cool
awesome
um second question was
um
like use it user interactivity has
dramatically changed between a user
Behavior Community Behavior has
dramatically changed on how people
interact with our facilities
um and some of the work that I had been
privy to with active Southland was that
you know like people will now drive to
destinations for physical play and Rec
rather than interact with their local
spaces
um as frequently so I wondered um you
know like with our um plans that we're
putting together and that like when we
when we're considering what we're going
to divest ourselves off or
um reduce levels of service and stuff
like that are we still in conversations
with the likes of the active South
London sport New Zealand absolutely
absolutely so they act out of the open
um spaces and places strategy yeah um is
our driving document when that comes
forward
um and yes you're right that people are
more prepared to uh travel
hopefully on a bike but potentially
however they want to travel
um we do need to balance that with those
that don't have disposable income or
disposable time to make sure that
there's still those opportunities
locally but it is a balancing act so I
understand what you're saying you're
correct when you look at the data I'm
just very cognizant of providing both of
those opportunities
yeah
um
just got back from being overseas which
has been fantastic because we've been a
really good reset but I've also noticed
a lot while I was over there
um
in terms of parks and rec and what other
councils are doing across the world and
one Council in particular that I thought
well that an area that I spent quite a
bit of time in
um was herefordshire and the council
have made a commitment to achieve carbon
neutrality by 2030 and part of the
strategy in doing that was that they
went through and they like reviewed all
of the Mullen areas that they currently
service
and then had a huge again I guess review
of that based on community benefit like
your procedure or Community outcomes
like you said and they're expected
expected levels of service
um so I guess my question is two-pronged
the first one is what are we doing like
how are we getting the community
expectations for level of service for
every facility and track like how we
Gathering that data
um to be able to feed into you know what
we do continue to reduce levels of
service level or
up levels of service of or divest or
whatever and the second one is um have
we got any kind of
aim to rather than just divesting
ourselves and selling off a whole lot of
land is there any plans for natural
regeneration and replanting and those
sorts of things for carbon neutrality
I can answer that second question so the
um the land disposal that we're looking
at we've all we've actually looked at
what the carbon sequestration would be
of those sites at the same time so that
we've actually got an overview of what
that would mean to us
um and going back to your first question
that was at the early stages of
implementing what those standards would
look like and we are absolutely
anticipating
um
doing community consultation on what
they're seeing and actually having their
they their needs and their understanding
what they want before we make changes so
we shouldn't be
um we shouldn't be providing something
that's not that people don't want we're
actually there for for the people at the
end of the day so yeah I think it's also
going to be a bit more of like a
behavior change for invercargillites as
well like if you I feel like sometimes
we get a little bit up and arms in a
particular piece of strip of of lawn
that we're used to seeing Marwan isn't
moan yeah
um so you know like the community the
environmental benefits of not mowing
there and the reduction and race and you
know like where that money that dollar
could be better spent by that pace just
being returned to Natural regeneration
chain yeah yeah we need to be really
really clear about why we're doing
things when we do them and when we
choose to do them so that people the
community can actually see exactly what
we're doing and why
to um to respond to your first question
um so we do have our management plans
that help us
outline what we do at each site
um at the moment we've got a general
policies management plan that's about to
go out for for review to actually get uh
the voice of the community into that
document
um and implementing the master plans to
inform our management plans is actually
going to be the way that we can
strategically shift what we do we've
found across New Zealand that if we just
roll over management plans there's not a
lot of change we roll over every 10
years and there's not a significant
shift to match the changing population
Dynamics but when you bring in the
strategy of Master plans that gives us
that tool to strategically shift and to
respond to your second question I would
say that one of the big rocks for my
team this year is actually a paper
around climate change impacts for
landscape design to actually be informed
by the science of what's the impact of
mowing the lawn versus having a sports
field at a different level of service
versus having a forest versus exotic
forest and all of those different
opportunities so we're cognizant of that
and that's in our wheelhouse at the
moment brilliant I look forward to
seeing the results
and final question Trish
Elizabeth Park I'm really pleased
since the introduction is a new BMX
track I've been down three or four times
because it's just amazing not for me
Chris can you pull that Mike in
um I think the new BMX track is amazing
but what I have noticed is that the old
BMX check I think it is or the part on
the back side of it is constantly used
by people absolutely our little
motorbikes there's fathers and kids and
things and it's quite nice it would be
quite nice to keep a space for that sort
of activity if that's what people want
yeah but it seems in the few times I've
been here that's what they're using it
for so uh you're correct
um and actually when the proposal was
put forward by Southland BMX to build a
new bigger brighter thing the agreement
at the time was at the end of that
project was to remove the existing BMX
track and parks and Rick we've put a bit
of a hold on that removal process and we
just want to review the site to make
sure that that's the right thing to do
because the review hasn't taken place
um but it didn't seem like the logical
thing to do in the first instance we
just wanted to go pause review let's
look at the whole site yeah that we can
take at all of Park approach rather than
just piecemeal yeah excellent thank you
my apologies Evelyn I missed your hand
sorry
um
I'm a South invercargill resident as
well and probably live the closest if
anybody to Russell Square
possibly
uh
and I don't disfavor extra investment
there but I am concerned that
um
we are missing out if we don't look more
intensely at Newbury Street and
Elizabeth Park because there is a
significant population of people in that
area who do not have the disposable
income to go other places
um you can walk there
you can scooter there you can ride your
bike there
um Elizabeth Park has the opportunity of
being a multi-generational space as
opposed to one particular age group and
I would really implore us as a council
to start thinking about that because we
don't have multi-generational spaces in
that area
um
even the risks
the the people with
um alternative
um motives for going places always exist
the best
way of preventing it is for
lots of adults and others being in those
spaces too
um unless they're also
hateful alternative motive
but will give everybody the benefit of
the doubt and say that spaces that
attract
parents with their children as well as
others are the most desirable activities
in our area particularly things that
encourage everybody to interact with one
another so you know a picnic table and a
and a place where you can set up a
barbecue all those sorts of things that
encourage families to be in spaces that
encourage people not to take their car
to spaces but also to really think of
South City as more than the Hub around
Alice Road and Grace Street and
delrumple street now that's easy for me
because I've lived in South invercargill
most of my life but I think that
if we want to make the city a vibrant
City for everybody we have to remember
that everybody cannot access
Queen's Park or the inner city
particularly on a Sunday because we do
not have public transport on Sunday so
encouraging people to use the spaces
proximate to them make them attractive
places to be is something that I think
we really should be focused on so I
thank you for the things that have been
said and offered sorry that I didn't
hear the whole conversation
um just the security in general
um is a huge issue
um
but some of it is all our own individual
responsibility to be aware and to be
reporting because I think that
sometimes we see something that's a
little bit often we think oh you know
it's fake to bring
um
555 or or whatever or in the city
council or you know
we need to do it
because it's our asset it belongs to all
of us the people are asset the safety of
our people and this investment that the
city makes and I'm not sure that
everybody
who
um we're engaging with actually
recognizes the cost to them as people of
the things that are happening that drive
people away from places and spaces you
know that allow the tagging
perhaps even encourage the tagging all
those things that diminish our our
public activity areas or even the beauty
of our space so you know I hate it that
people feel unsafe anywhere in this city
but how much of it is down to us turning
a blind eye to stuff or not prioritizing
it and I just don't know the answer and
I don't know how you encourage people to
be more aware and to be more socially
responsible but
um but thank you for the
um thing just the last thing is the um
retiring ground from mowing
um we don't have as many
indigenous wildflowers as we could have
so the flower Meadow type things that we
see in other countries is not something
that I want to encourage because Ubi
might be encouraging some of those peace
plants that I'm not as keen on but I do
think that
um
we're a little bit attached to our
manicured spaces at the cost of our
indigenous vegetation and the species
that live within them and so I applaud
the fact that we're having the
discussion thank you
I've got two hands that have just gone
up and I'm going to start shortening
your break ground well and that I'll be
very quick then
um just going back to my
um
request around pragmatic I'm interested
to understand how you would prioritize
your work around climate change versus
security
at Sandy Point and bringing forward the
master plan
so which one
as Caroline previously said that's going
to be implemented through the management
plan so the master plan is the overall
strategic Direction but implementing and
finding those environment-based
Solutions
is a part of the management plan so
that's not able to be answered sorry
well I must heard you but I heard you
say you you know your climate change
mitigation carbon was in your wheelhouse
and you're going to make that a priority
you know what I'm really pointing at is
you know Community safety ranks much
higher in my view than climate change
you know because the reality is you know
and I've had it described to me by a
scientist and a crowd of a hundred
thousand people the impact that New
Zealand has on climate change is one
person passing wind you know so and I
think it's also ironic and I apologize
in advance Alex but you know we can be
pragmatic about that but you know flying
is a very significant impact on carbon
any in environment so you know we've got
to be pragmatic around the fact that
Community safety and what everyone's
saying is absolutely important and some
other things that might be you know
politically motivated or may be of
importance because it gets a headline
need to be sort of understood
so against the science of you know
hundred thousand people one person
passing wind it's you know that's a
reality
uh thanks you're right
um thanks I would like to say that
they're not in isolation we can achieve
both of those things together so we can
increase the security of our people
through environmental design and so we
have siptid issues across the country
where we across the city sorry where we
don't actually provide a safe place for
our residents but they don't occur in
isolation so we can have increased
security for our people if we design the
space correctly
foreign
on the issue disposing of land
um it's it's too simple just to say well
we won't mow it anymore we'll convert it
into native Bush and we'll get some
carboot there because the alternative is
that you convert it into some
um some residential space which is what
we desperately need in the city now
people would still sit back and say well
residential property development on a
piece of land that we currently mow is
not good for carbon but the alternative
is you then push the spread further out
so you you convert your bit of land that
might be a few hectares which you can
put quite a few houses on and and that's
good for carbon but it's not so good
when that those houses then need to be
located on the side of your city which
pushes your infrastructure out and just
it pushes everything up so I guess just
reflecting on that
um I was interesting what even I had to
say about security
um we've learned to know the time that
we had two options for a venue for uh
the pump track one was up in Grant Road
and one was right on the mains the main
Highway going into town and there's a
lot of pushback about the being by the
main road but with hindsight it's by far
the best place because the young
children and families with young
children feel very safe there because
it's very visible if we've gone to Grant
Road there would have been other issues
that only two or three eyes are on on
that space and then the teenagers do
what teenagers do and so on and the
other thing I would reflect is what I
think partner raised as well was the
issue the urgent need to have a toilet
in Russell Square I know it's only
agenda and we've got the same thing with
the pump Tracker out of town because
people just go into the boys and do what
they need to do and it's not all that
good going forward so but it's probably
more urgent than Russell Square yeah so
I think there is still a bit when you
want people to be safe
um putting them in a city area I hear
what everyone said about pushing it out
in the summit suburbs
um but the one good thing about the
inner city being on Queens Drive is the
same as being on I'd uh dundro as the
kids are very very safe there's no
potential for Predators or for any
standover tactics from the older kids or
anything like that because it's very
visible people are constantly going past
it so if there's any fights or anything
you know it's much safer for the very
young children
thank you Jim okay
ex-councilors thank you both very much
for coming along and and presenting
castles here's where we'll take a break
and June uh the stream will stop
um and we will be reconvening at five to
eleven so if you could be ready to go at
that point thank you
uh we'll start the stream again
okay welcome back for those joining us
on the live stream as we continue our um
long-term plan Workshop looking at asset
and activity plans and uh we'll move
into libraries
it's a good time to go for a glass of
water Richard you've had 20 minutes
and drop and give me 10.
[Laughter]
we were tidied away all right it's
better than listening to the incessant
coughing everyone
okay I'm here to talk around uh
libraries
so
um just an overview of the activity uh
the invercargill library opens open
seven days a week so it's 62 hours of
service and we've also got the bluff
Library six days a week for 43 hours and
of course we've got our 24 7 online
service and that's growing um year on
year in terms of that digital
consumption of of content
uh the mechanical Library opening hours
provide access to community archives
programs are provided to support
literacy and Community well-being and
services are provided to support Equity
of access we've got a range of
collections available to support
recreational reading lifelong learning
and community and local history one of
the most important things to the library
it's a place for people to come together
so it's about social cohesion and we use
information and Gathering as that tool
if you like to build that social
cohesion it's used to be you know
information information it's now much
more about information how we interpret
it and how we actually understand each
other and discover and be inspired
some extras there from the library
Okay so we've got our well-beings here
our social well-being it's it's about
social infrastructure and we want to do
more work to become a safe and Equitable
place to become connected for our
communities to build a better future for
themselves as well as both in person and
online
cultural well-being the library does
provide a lot of public programs that
engage communities these are fun
programs to do but they're also based on
education curriculum and specific needs
of our community the environmental
well-being the library provides
resources to support sustainability and
ensure programming will help support
wider outcomes in this area so a library
can be used by Council as a tool for
communication as a place for
intergenerational Learning and on topics
that are important to council
and of course the economic well-being
the library supports literacy which is
strongly related to the educational
success and economic well-being of a
society so it's really important that we
have people that can access information
upskill themselves learn and add to the
thriving economy
our current budget so the headline here
is we're pretty much 95 rates income a
modest Revenue which is things like our
hot picks uh our venue hire Etc
down the bottom we've got um 30fte and a
head count of 33 and we've got a small
collection of casuals it's important to
notice that uh in this sort of uh an
operation the casuals often do backfill
we can't simply have people away sick
and put the the work on a shelf we do
require to maintain a health health and
safety in the weekends Etc so often the
casuals are used for backfill
um in our operations
maintaining the levels of service so as
I've already alluded to the libraries
are a place for social cohesion and
they're growing and involving as
Community hubs as well so there's many
things that they can do and this will
change some of the skills and services
that we require in the library space in
the future
the digital space is rapidly changing
and we'll need to keep pace and both of
with the staff and the community needs
and the level Services need to be
maintained through continual renewal of
budgets including renewing the impact of
reviewing the impact of programs as its
stock market digital to ensure that
where we spend the money is the right
places so we're continually reviewing
that we're trying to understand what
that migration from physical to online
might be and what the tolerance there is
and how we actually uh progress I don't
think there'll ever be a stage when it's
completely online and digital people
still like to thumb through a book
libraries will continue to look for
opportunities for increased
collaboration we really with a new
strategy in place we want to reach out
and become part of the community a lot
more so we want to look at exploring and
utilizing and leveraging the information
and skills of the community to deliver
our programs
libraries will also continue to monitor
resource levels to ensure we keep Pace
with growth and demand not just in our
Central Library but also with Bluff and
around the city so taking our services
outside of those four walls
requirements to maintain compliance now
we need fit for purpose opening hours
and we've had discussions now with as we
work through the implementation the new
strategy about are we opening the right
times for the right people and we will
do a little bit more work in exploring
when those opening hours are and when
programs are delivered we want to
maintain and refresh collections we need
a fit for purpose building So currently
we've got a building that has leaks in
the roof and we put out buckets so we
actually want to address that and ensure
that we are proud of our facility
we want a range of programs to support
lifelong learning and literacy obviously
we want to provide the Wi-Fi and
continue that internet access for equity
and up to date and in additional
infrastructure and communication support
we want to tell people more about the
sorts of things that we do in the
library
here's some uh selection of our various
programs so you can see the not to store
books there's all sorts of things up
there we do justice of the piece we have
digital access we have 3D printing let's
say pineapple there as well as uh
performance and competition stuff
so opportunities for cost savings or end
increased Revenue we want to take a
balanced approach to our to increase the
use of commercial meeting room hires and
look sensibly to monetize Services where
appropriate now that sounds particularly
capitalist but don't don't worry we want
to have a balanced approach we want to
understand what programs are really
really important for equity and access
but also what programs are perhaps more
entertainment and could have a charge we
did a trial earlier this year where we
had a An Evening
Star Wars quiz night and we charged a
modest entry to that it wasn't deprived
in anyone of illiteracy but it was
actually really well subscribed people
loved it and they were prepared to pay
so we're just looking at that balanced
approach
at the library management software is up
for Renewal and we're looking to join a
consortia to bring us more in line with
the other libraries and also reduce some
of the uh our internal I.T resources
the library is going to continue to
explore and increase Partnerships
especially in that program development
and delivery so we get the experts in
the community and uh to deliver and
Design
the library has a program of continuous
review and Improvement and procurement
so we really want to explore where we
are purchasing and are we getting best
bang for buck and it's a it's a timely
opportunity to go back and just revisit
uh how we we manage that
proposals for a new or lifted level of
service so we want to Future proof the
library service and we need to stay
current with Digital Trends so this is
really just a heads up
um we look we talk about artificial
intelligences all over the news at the
moment we need to understand that more
and be prepared for what that means in
terms of virtual services and resources
because there are both challenges and
opportunities there
these are just heads up we're not asking
uh for any particular bids for these the
library also acknowledges that we need
to respond to the growing social role in
libraries in the community in the
well-being space and there'll be actions
within our implementation plan of the
strategy to actually acknowledge that
and the skill levels required we also
acknowledge that we want to move out of
the library four walls and explore
mobile pop-up options to take the
library out to where the users are for
those people who can't necessarily
travel housebound
Etc so we want to really explore and
promote that Service as well so that's
all with done within our existing
envelope
Now options for Council to consider this
is really a long term heads up we really
want to explore
um and a timely um conversation in the
future will be library's role as a full
Council customer service side are there
other customer customer service roles
that we could actually help to provide
to enable a seven day access to some of
our service so we're well and truly open
to that conversation in the future we're
not ready yet and our infrastructure
isn't ready but that is something that
will happen in the future
we also want to explore future provision
Branch libraries now
um as the city grows we will in the
future have a conversation around Bluff
which effectively is a pop-up library at
the moment but there may well be a
conversation around branch libraries do
we need a branch library and Bluff in 20
years time in South City in Windsor
those are the conversations if it's or a
mobile option so those are the
conversations that will happen in the
future and we need to be prepared for
that
uh and the last one is uh opportunity
for a cafe and other Revenue generation
activities this is more immediate we are
going to start to explore that balance
between commercial activity on site and
the community and that's within the
bounds of the strategy and so things
like
um a coffee cart and the four court and
something that just generates a little
bit of income that sort of thing we will
explore without compromising that core
customer service that we've committed to
performance so libraries
actively enhances our city through
ensuring the library collections both
digital and physical offer quality
quantity and a variety of resources we
want to make sure that all of our
services are available to everyone we
want to
ensure that we're telling the good story
of the library and people really rate
the library as satisfactory or Grace so
we want to be at the the living room of
the library if you like the heart and
the soul of the community in the city
center
here's our kpis so it's the percentage
of the collection published in the last
five years so this is excluding the
Heritage collection and this is a a
measure that enables us to describe how
current our stock is on the Shelf so
we're not got Dusty old books we've got
relevant authentic
um desired books the next one is the
percentage of Library customers who rate
the library satisfactory or greater and
as an annual residence survey that's
pretty self-explanatory we also a number
of visits per year we also
obviously that a consumption thing we
want to continue to track and remember
the number of visits is not just
physical visits we have digital visits
as well so we want to provide that data
and have a data Rich environment we've
got a draft uh kpi there about
engagement with programs and events is
maintained or increasing we currently
provide stats to a National Database
around our programs but we actually
don't report them back to council and we
thought that's something you'd like to
know so we want to be able to tell you
how many people are coming in for things
other than just information so that
social connection thing
uh and the second draft one is a
collection usage including digital
resources is maintained or increasing so
we want to make sure that the things
that are on our shelves that are in our
digital
um stores are being used accessed and
relevant so we're making room for a new
stock as well as reviewing uh the shelf
life of of what we already have
so
um that's the quick overview we've
obviously got just uh um before we go
into questions we've we've got a new
strategy at the moment in time we are
reviewing what that really means on the
ground so we're doing lots of workshops
with the staff we've got uh the library
manager role out in the marketplace and
we'll move to interviews shortly for
that and then we will start to look at
some tangible kind of rubber hits the
road so there's no big asks in there
because we've got a a road map of uh
where we want to be and and that's
really a moment to take a breath and
start to consolidate what we've got and
and develop so nothing too scary up here
of the chase permission go through
questions thank you Trish
um
do you consider first of all
congratulations it sounds great and I
love what you're doing especially the
extra nights and things I was thinking
about the Star Wars night or your kids
night do you consider not just kids
dress you'll be surprised yeah
some kind of Transport you know
connecting with the transport people to
get
um access to the library on those nights
yeah access is a really interesting
thing and that's um I mean most of our
conversations to be honest have been
about how can we take our service out to
the community we did uh a bit of a bias
here we did a Mr yippity show which is a
children's sort of um like a solo wiggle
is about how I can best describe it and
we actually did it rather than crammed
into the back of the library we did it
over the Scottish Hall and we have
pop-up banners that said pop-up Library
so we're trying to take the services out
more than trying to get people in but I
shouldn't take a point about that
coordination aspect because I think as
we look and think about opening hours as
well we've got to make sure that it's
not just open but it's convenient for
Access and parking Etc yeah and it's
also that excitement for people on going
somewhere I'm thinking more students you
know going somewhere where they don't
usually go on a night there's a bit of
that possessed Style
really interesting with the promotion
that happened about we so we had some
students stay in the library overnight
as a bit of a promotion for the 40-hour
challenge and then the radio picked up
um a conversation about where would you
like to stay the night in invercargill
and Library came up quite a bit there's
quite a few people you know as a
destination which was fascinating so
there is interest out there and and that
after hours kind of stuff I think that's
the free Wi-Fi
potentially
having having had teenagers uh Tom
uh I think libraries have always played
a really important social role and you
know it's always been ever since you
know I think libraries began a place
that people can go and be warm
and dry and be in the company other
people and you know better themselves
actually
may I read newspapers or whatever so I I
think you know the continuation of that
rule and expansion of that rule I think
you know I would definitely support I
think it's always been part of all the
libraries but
um you know maybe it needs expanded the
the question I had is about the physical
books
so I mean obviously there's a I I wish
to maintain the collection a very high
standard but I suspect and when I say I
suspect this is a question you're going
to create me I'm sure but I suspected
whereas a book may have been
you know read by 100 people before maybe
it's read by 10 now or something like
that
um a physical book
is that an issue when it comes to you
know how how do we judge how many
physical books we need to have as
opposed to how many screens we need to
have for him you know access digitally
that we offer people
I'm not going to correct you because
you're you're absolutely right and it is
a challenge going forward so we do we
have a process a weeding process so we
look at the number of um so we purchase
a book based on the demographics and the
trends and we do have data and external
companies that tell us what to buy that
help us and then we put our own flavor
on top of it and then we look at the
usership over a period of time and and
so the ones that don't go out and
sometimes you do get it wrong and the
ones that don't go out you end up on a
weeding shelf and um they get uh
disposed of or if we think it's just a
temporary lull they'll go on the back
for storage so things like them will use
children's because it's a it's a really
uh illustrative point if Dora the
Explorer comes on telly then we need a
heck of a lot of Dora the Explorer box
because every child is going to come in
and demand the next year that might go
off for a season and no one's interested
in Dora the Explorer so there are EBS
and flows we do monitor it sometimes we
don't get it right and sometimes we need
more of one thing or more of one thing
for a Time the interesting thing with
physical stock is the same thing happens
with digital stock you think oh digital
stock you can just keep on the shelf
forever but in fact it has a limited
number of times you can take it out
before it needs to be replaced as well
under the license so we are continually
reviewing it we want to tighten that up
and we want to ask some questions around
is the where we invest in collections is
it in the right proportion and stock
because I can collection is not just
books online and physical but there's
also digital equipment
um all of that kind of business as well
supplementary chip sort of if
you look at the
say the number of physical books that we
used to purchase say 10 years or 20
years ago how does that compare with the
number that we purchase now yeah
so the
um the budget hasn't reduced the budget
stayed pretty stable
accounting with inflation Etc but we're
buying less physical books and more
digital copies so we've talked uh and
and in terms of a it's an interesting
conversation about what what is an asset
versus you know what's capex versus RPX
because uh physical items are taken
subscriptions rather have taken the
place of part of our physical stock so
we might only have one physical copy and
one digital copy as opposed to
previously we may have had two physical
copies so there is a a crossover
um it's physical copies are declining
and digital is increasing not to the
point that we think it's going to settle
at a point it's not going to be
completely digital people still like the
books and when you talk to people
they'll often say I'll only read one one
book on a Kindle and then I'll have a
second book by the bed you know they
want their balance but we are tracking
that yeah thank you you can't beat that
tactile experience you can't thumb
through a iPad and get that same sense
of smell being stimulated Grant yeah
thanks to you um Richard yeah firstly
you know I think the law was in safe
hands with you sort of Leaning into that
and getting a good strategic outcome so
um appreciate your work just a couple of
questions Lord do you still have to have
a library card to
you know take books out or access
you do at the moment yes and so what
what what are the numbers the library
cards doing are they going up going down
static uh no our membership is going up
um at the rate that we'd expect you know
according to the demographics so it's
still popular demand and that yeah cool
in in your sort of sense
if we think about it from a conceptual
thing is it and you know are we looking
at a strategy of a library with services
or are we looking more at a community
Hub with Library Services if you took a
10-year view that's a pretty new
question and there are some councils in
New Zealand who build new facilities
that purposely and deliberately do not
call them libraries libraries have a lot
of baggage
um uh we're not ready for that yet but I
think they will be Community hubs more
and more
um the there's information everywhere
now you don't have to rely on on a
library to get your information but you
may have to rely on your library to in
your school in terms of how you
interpret that information so I think
yeah there is certainly the community
Hub
um uh thing happening more and more the
one caveat to that Evolution would be
that we've got effectively essential
Library so if we dial forward 20 years
we might not be sitting in a singular
City Council we might be something
bigger with many branches depending on
the growth or anything else that happens
politically at which point we will
probably still do the heavy lifting in
terms of those librarianship
uh services so as a Central Library
there's always going to be the need for
research there's always going to be the
need for a repository of local and
special collections so we will continue
that so we will never fully evolve into
a um you know a really uh organic sort
of community center the way libraries
are peripheral right that's a box of
peripheral yeah okay thank you Alex
um thank you
um I just wanted to check how do you get
the information to inform what kind of
programs that you should run so for both
adults and kids so how do we get that
information that kids want to you know
like skills literacy stuff on
how to build a terrarium yeah or 3D
printing or what and then again how do
you know that the Star Wars stuff is
going to be successful absolutely so
um to be completely Frank we've had an
ad hoc
um response to programming in the past
and it's been based on the interest or
the experience of Staff or who they've
met or the response from Community you'd
be recall that a few months ago we um
bought the arangaranga programming
framework too which is a way of using
science to develop that so that's where
we're moving to
um so sometimes we get it wrong uh
sometimes we have uh huge successes so
and sometimes it's surprising so we add
we've got a permission
um based a
permission to risk and stuff up at the
moment but we are using rangaranga so
we're having regular meetings with the
rest of council to try and develop and
build on that programming skill
interesting with knights of the art and
night of the Arts we had a few things
out there that we thought oh I don't
know whether this is going to work so we
had our virtual reality PlayStation
right in the middle of the library
amongst the the books and stuff
um we had a which is very noisy we had
Celtic singing around the corner and we
had a Lego wall and face painting and
look it worked really well so it's even
then that programming taking it out of
that back room and into the space
surprised us that we could actually do
that without being disruptive to other
people not all the time but we're
learning with programming yeah
Evelyn
cheddar Richard
um a few things
the difference between the Heritage
collection and books that are no longer
current but may still be really useful
particularly for researchers and I and I
recognize there is a balance but not
everything that
um
I don't know is in the 1968 Encyclopedia
Britannica for example has been
superseded by modern knowledge there's
something quite reassuring about going
and finding that
the online version still says what the
1968 version says if we're researching
something and you're wanting to track
changes over time and thinking and
things like that how do we balance that
because that's not strictly speaking Our
Heritage item yeah but it has value to
researchers what do we keep what do we
not keep we had a really interesting
conversation a couple weeks ago about
um misinformation or disinformation in
books and then we discovered that
probably a lot of our books have got
misinformation is Pluto a planet you
know you'll have various books same
different things
um to that point uh we have got the
local collection out the back which we
keep and now that is a collection of
things that aren't necessarily
duplicated at a national level
things with an ISBN number is vested in
the National Library we've got a much
more sophisticated interloan system now
where we can Source those other books if
for and we have positions specifically
around customer responsiveness and that
research so if someone wants to book a
librarian book a research person they
can actually find those volumes
elsewhere so it's less important what we
are going to do moving forward is the
local collection we've got a desire to
completely digitize that as well so
we're not those One Singular copies that
are the minute box of
someone a local community group or a bit
of research that's been done before we
don't want to risk having just a
singular physical copy so we are looking
to digitize them but our safety net is
that um the national library and our
Interline and the ability to be able to
see other collections Across the Nation
and we've got a really sophisticated
network of Library management software
and what we're looking to evolve in our
library management software will
increase our capability to find those
volumes too
um so thank you for that the going out
and about thing now
we're used to at one stage because I
think we had a um acquaintance who may
have been in the building have a
collection of books for different age
groups at the Mirai is that something
that you wish to expand on so that
um you know you talked about the mobile
I think somebody rocks up at one of our
um
uh Community Villages or something like
that and
you know bearing in mind again that
these are people that sometimes become
isolated
by physical limitations or financial
limitations that sort of idea or yep so
currently we have we do that for a
number of Rest Homes and we have
dementia care that we go out and we take
selections and we select them for those
clients in terms of their desires and
stuff we also have housebound service so
people who are housebound we can deliver
books to them now
um typically that's the Elder community
and those with severely limited uh
accessibility issues but that's not
Susan Stone it could be for anyone that
we determine as a vulnerable Community
or that could benefit from that Outreach
service we just don't have necessarily
the physical assets to be able to do a
lot of it is this but with the provision
is actually there as a service so I
guess it's a not so well known service
that you provide and it's limited by
some constraints at the moment yeah
exactly and so my last one which is
probably the awful one is you're talking
about digitizing
and you're talking about
um
those sorts of platforms and including
core Tui
um how compatible is that going to be
with the digitization that is already
going on within our some of our Museum
and other archives
are they going to be compatible are they
going to be searchable across all the
things
um and uh or are they competing for a
quite limited technological resource
within this very institution because I'm
this is something that I'm quite
passionate about and I'm curious about
so in terms of cataloging that's not an
issue so both the new the existing the
new library software can catalog
digitization also not a big issue in
terms of we are just simply digitizing
what you're talking about is access to
those digital things and that is
something that is unresolved at the
moment so our first priority is to make
sure that our local collection and those
special things are secure and on a
pathway to get them onto a file we have
not resolved how that file will be
accessed at a on an online certainly
someone can come in and we can say yes
we can get that file for you but we
don't have an access and that's
something that has been discussed with
both archives and future Museum
developments how do we make those
collections available online
um yeah for me I think it's important
that it goes back to that that research
and all those sorts of things people not
having to visit two or three different
places where it should be reasonably
seamless within the within
our group of facilities so thank you for
that
thank you through the questions
thank you Mr chair I have to start by
saying librarianship was my first
profession
so I have to make the Declaration that
the physical book will never die
it will increase having computerized
three libraries in my career because
when I started all Ivy libraries were
entirely menu run you produced a little
card you had a series of cards for
standings putting it putting in and out
you had paper Kettle card catalogs
um so I suppose the the point I would
make is the library world has changed
dramatically and will continue the
change I once won a librarianship debate
by proving that the safest and easiest
to run Public Library was the one where
you put the stock on the shelves and
then turned the key you close the doors
so that you had a non-lending lending
library
the most efficient Library you will ever
run however it is a totally
um
a totally pointless exercise from the
point of view of what libraries are
about which is increasingly to be in
that social space and to actually
deliver
um that social well-being element
um as far as the digitization and the
question that councilor Campbell raised
about how many books do you have at
physical books do you have as against no
what's the balance of your stock and so
forth I think we do have to rely on the
professional Judgment of the profession
as to how that particular aspect is
going to develop as I say the book will
never die but Richard is Right nowadays
you might have one physical copy in for
high demand stock two or three digital
copies and and what you're putting in
your stack rooms is very much a
professional judgment that we as a
council have to rely on the Librarians
we employ making but look Richard I just
want to say I've read every report on a
public library and the bluff library
with great interest I think that there's
some fantastic things being done to
develop a library in the spaces that
needs to be developed in I'm really
pleased to see the the
um New cataloging is going to more and
more
rely on the
National Library of New Zealand
standards and so forth because that's
excellent
um having set up a couple of
housebound services in my time I
definitely see that we need to develop
on that whole Space of the housebound
Services the Outreach programs possibly
mobile
it's a um
it's just something we accept as as a
fairly standard part of what we do in
the future
about the the library I think we've got
a fantastic team they've been doing some
really good work in that space of how do
you use the library as a community Hub
every time I go into the library and I'm
a regular User it's really interesting
to see who is there in the spaces and
what they are doing so you've got their
whole mixture of the people who are
there to use the free Wi-Fi the young
people who are there because we have an
excellent
um ya collection
um in we've got the digital space and
the
the print 3D printing and so forth it
was really interesting to go in on the
evening and see just what was happening
with
the visual reality and the Lego and and
how it all integrated together I think I
think our staff have really managed to
get a good balance of how the spaces are
being used
so yeah just
just continue on and I think we are
going to develop more and more into that
space of the of the living room of the
community and I think that's a good
thing it's it's it's the philosophy with
which I started my career and I think
it's become more and more the philosophy
of every
librarian as things have developed that
that libraries won't survive if you do
if if anyone does think locking the door
and throwing away the key is the way to
go libraries won't survive but the vet
does they survive because they're a
loving part of their communities and
responding to community needs thank you
and I should just point out two things
you just reminded me of our housebound
service this is a plug now for those
people listening at home our housebound
service does actually rely partly on
volunteers so we have volunteers that
actually help deliver box
um and part of when you deliver a book
you're not just delivering a book you
are having a conversation and making a
connection and brightening someone's day
the second point I just wanted to I
realized I hadn't got up there on
average would have around about a
thousand people through the library
every day and so on night of the Arts we
just tipped into 1 500 people in a
single day and they are coming from all
walks of life and it's time to to
mention that because often you go into
the library and you do see you know 50
people in there but you know you don't
get a sense of how often that's
refreshed during the day
thanks literally good point because you
know you can never replace a good book
burning
um it's really hard to ignite a tablet
or a laptop
has it got the same feel you don't get
the same warm comforting glow that's
right and the book is the best thing to
read at night in bed yeah
although that's it there's nothing like
reverse lighting your iPad because you
can the small hours
no it hasn't got the same feel to it so
I'm reliably informed
um thank you Richard uh Jason do you
want to come up and take a seat with
Richard and we'll transition from
libraries into venues Richard if you
need to top up your uh vodka I mean
water
I'm Richard
okay so same format uh the only
difference here is I know there's two
things in here that you're going to want
to have a discussion around so I've just
done the general service first ending
with the um measures kpis and then the
the two media bets that you might have
interest in at the end okay
so
you all know this The Avengers event
service operates the Civic Theater the
Scottish Hall and rugby park
this includes the hiring the event
ticketing and also the delivery and
coordination of specialist services to
enable safe and engaging events to occur
so yes we are halls for hire effectively
but in turn that we are helping build
capacity in the event sector we are
talking people through the health and
safety plans making sure that they are
marketing and ticketing their events
appropriately and have considered all
the things so in our portfolio at the
Civic Theater as you know is a thousand
seat professional standard Lyric Theater
meeting rooms hospitality and a small
performance space so this is largely
aimed at the commercial end of things
and it balances out through income those
other more Community
venues that we have there is an access
program as we had a workshop on a little
while ago to enable Community to use the
Civic Scottish Hall it's got a main hall
plus with movable seats which is really
really important for those social uh
functions for communities it's also got
a a community Lounge at the back in the
commercial kitchen in our upstairs
office and meeting rooms in space so the
Scottish Hall is designed to be robust
used by the community primarily it does
have some commercial activity over there
but first and foremost it is a place for
our community to be able to gather it
doesn't need all of the
um accoutrement that the Civic needs in
terms of Staffing and because the
equipment is easier to use and safer to
use Etc so very very accessible the
higher rates are equally accessible then
we've got rugby park owned by the
invercargill city charitable trust and
managed by us which is obviously the
grandstand to change rooms the media
tower and then the social and corporate
spaces on that site
Anderson house so we give limited sport
so that's uh third party operates
Anderson house and we provide them with
uh Services ticketing equipment hire
from time to time
so strategic priorities in terms of our
community well-beings and Community
outcomes rather so we've got social
well-being so venues provide again
spaces for people to come together to
connect celebrate learn and share
stories
um that are important to them it's a
really important thing in terms of uh
social cohesion civic pride is to
actually understand who we are as people
as a community what makes us different
as southlanders uh what our history who
have been the generations who have
walked this Earth before us and that
happens often through stories and
stories could be in a library but they
could also be presented on the stage
so cultural well-beings we enable events
to add to the vibrancy and range of
opportunities for people to be
entertained so in terms of cultural
well-being it's a really important uh
that we explore different ideas
different viewpoints and again these are
often presented through performance
environmental well-being continued
provision of local facilities and events
reduce the need for communities to
travel long distances to engage with
sporting and performance events without
a rugby park without a Civic Theater
where would people go and they would go
to Dunedin or Queenstown that would have
a significant impact on your carbon
footprint over the years have already
been discussed about flying Etc so
having local facilities I'm sorry go to
a look then having local facilities
provide that is actually really really
important and last one is economic
well-being venues are a significant
contributor to the nighttime economy so
having something that actually generates
a reason for people to come into town to
spend money to stay overnight is
actually really important we know some
of our performances that touring
performances have come through May
attract up to 20 to 30 percent of out of
town people who will stay the night have
a meal
um have a drink Etc so that's all really
important it also adds to the
destination appeal of invercargill the
attractiveness to the potential
businesses and employees and job Force
Workforce
current budget so
um
roughly about a million dollars and
that's 50 uh General rates and 50 uh
um income generation now that's uh our
Target but of course we're a commercial
activity and we operate in a commercial
way which means that we often typically
sit around the 60 40 by the time uh
We've generated additional income
uh look the rft count is six with a head
count of six so
um that's a small number of people to
operate at multiple sites so we rely on
casual staff and that's what that note
just inside to see is so event staff so
typically to to open uh the Civic we
might have we could have 10 or 12 people
actually employed that night their
employed casuals and then they are
charged on to the higher the person
who's actually hired um the cost of of
the venue so it's a bit deceptive to say
there's only six people floating around
and thinking that um we're doing all
these things we do have casuals but
they're not out of our sales and wages
budget question does that include the
catering stuff no that doesn't include
catering catering is completely
outsourced to the ilt delivered via the
ascot
exclusively yes that's a contract that
came in as a result of the funding that
they provided for the upgrade of the
Civic that is that Arrangement is
nearing the end of life I think yes and
there is an opportunity uh to
renegotiate and have a discussion around
the hospitality provision and we will do
that in partnership with ilt
um and we've also got from time to time
we have ticketing staff over at the
Civic to reduce pressure of customer
services when they have in particularly
High workflow but at the moment
ticketing is primarily through uh
customer services downstairs it was at
the stadium as well and the Chamber as
well so we're now down to just
downstairs
in the future provision over there we
will have a ticketing uh 0.5 of a person
that's included in those numbers there
we don't have ticketing available in
person at the moment on weekends as a
result of the stadium departure from the
network but we do have 24 7 online
access
so to maintain our current level of
service now we obviously need to
maintain fit for purpose and safe
um uh
um venues we also need to maintain the
Heritage and thematic presentation of
The Vineyards that's just a way of
saying that a lot of the reason why we
generate income is because it's a
special and different and interesting
place so we need to make sure that we
maintain that special different and
interesting place and not fall behind
the presentation is effectively that
what we're selling to maintain a level
of service the business also needs to
ensure a balance of commercial and
Community activity so we can't go one
direction or the other we can't go
completely commercial because that would
come at a cost of all those good things
that we're talking about for the
community we also can't go completely
Community because we rely on that
commercial to subsidize those other
venues such as the Scottish Hall Etc
the levels of service also need to be
maintained by continual renewal of
budgets
Avenues will continue to seek
opportunities for increased
collaboration and Partnerships as to
grow the business and Community
capability in the event space so that
what that's saying there is that we want
to walk hand in hand a lot more than
what we've done in the past to build
that capacity of our community groups
higher in our education Partners so in
the future they have more capacity and
can come back and hire it in a
professional space
requirements to maintain compliance so
for us we need to maintain our opening
hours and access to ticketing ticketing
is really really important although
we're collecting other people's money we
need to ensure that that service is
um is really just booming because uh
full houses mean those promoters and
those community events continue to
happen and they come back year on year
we also need to maintain the buildings
for renewals and programmed maintenance
to ensure Public Safety so that's we've
had lots of conversations around that in
the past particularly with rugby park
and we need to maintain our plants and
Equipment through renewals as well as
response and program maintenance to
ensure Public Safety as well and we also
need to address accessibility to our
venues we often talk about accessibility
be then think of uh of wheelchair users
Etc but we're we're all getting older
and we are all
um we've we know we're going to have an
aging population and accessibility means
people with cataracts people hard of
hearing people who find those extra
steers a little bit difficult it's not
just wheelchair users it's going to be
all of us very shortly so we need to
make sure that we are uh addressing that
and now Heritage facilities
opportunities for cost savings so look
we operation the commercial World
um and we want to increase our
commercial growth
um to thus further reduce rate per phone
and so we are we are focused on some
parts of our building some parts of our
business rather making money and so that
means that's a better way than cutting
often and so venues want to further
explore opportunities for commercial
activation diversification of spaces
including medium-term hires I think we
could all see the benefit of not just
the social role but the economic role of
having the covet clinic in an
underutilized room upstairs in the Civic
we want to explore more things like that
we're here using the Civic as a voting
Hub later this year for general
elections so again those sort of
week-long hires are really really
important we want to really you know
unlock some of those spaces that we've
got
we want to renegotiate our service
contracts to more of a partnership model
so in some of our facilities our
relationship with our service delivery
Partners is very one-sided so we want to
actually involve them in our business
direction that that would be things like
catering provision things like security
all of those things we want to really
say actually we're both in This Together
how can we align our goals um and and
get a bit more of a parchment model
venues has a program of continuous
review and Improvement in the
procurement and supply of resources to
maximize efficiency so you've used that
twice in two presentations because it
was such a good line so in other words
we just want to make sure that we've got
a good procurement
um in place so we're getting the best
deal and we know there are some things
we can unlock by uh better communication
with the risk of council so we want to
explore that to make sure we're getting
the best deal for for paying for back
proposals for newer lifted services so
these the two proposals here they're
both cost neutral and they're both
things that we intend to do at a
operational level in the existing
budgets
so the first one we already do a little
bit low risk co-producing self-produced
events this in other words we want to be
able to do stuff ourselves when we see
an opportunity or a gap via using the
programming framework we want to say
actually there's a gap there we can
actually do that small program we're not
talking about staging uh huge shows in
the Civic or anything like that but the
example of that um the children's show
across the road done by the libraries
was a great way to actually promote our
venue at a low level and co-produce it
and so we want to balance our commercial
return from ticket events as well as
free community events there are times
when we have lots of people come through
the door and we can just add to that by
adding a free program out the front
um so we want to do that we also want to
increase civic pride environment see in
this city so that's similar to the
taking the library outside of the
um building from time to time we want to
take the expertise that we have and the
staff and the equipment that we have
there and take it outside to the
community and that might be really small
it might be sharing our bean bag
collection with the Community Markets
that happen around the place or it might
be something more where we actually are
helping do an event
next one is increased ticketing Services
level we want to increase access to
ticketing Services through longer
opening hours and more locations we want
to explore doing that with Council
facilities so we do have some facilities
that are open seven days and have a good
relationship with the library manager
and I mean constant talks about could we
potentially even use the library as a
outlet for ticketing you know we also
have other facilities open on the
weekends and later at night so we're not
talking about creating new
um kiosks anywhere but actually
expanding those tickling Services where
it makes sense
and that's self-funded through extra
revenue and using existing resources
do those conversations happen like this
with that manager I constantly have
multiple voices in my head
[Laughter]
uh levels of service so measuring
performance
um obviously uh we want to measure
performance of both our assets and the
services within them we do that
primarily through
our recent survey we want to just
tighten that up a little bit and make
sure we're asking the right questions of
our recent survey as well as start to
ask the questions of our promoters and
hireers who often aren't our residents
but they are our income line so we want
to include increase public use of venue
I can barely read that gosh that was
small Richard uh increased public use of
venue Services through attraction and
support of a range of community events
through touring shows and performances
so we want to measure the different
types of shows and understand where the
gaps are and where the events are what
sporting codes have been provided for
ETC what shows and genres are coming
through obviously the number of visits
per head of invercargill population is a
really valuable one and down the bottom
is that satisfaction of our hirers and
our patrons so the people paying for the
hire but also those people coming to see
the shows
and they rate the experience of the
venue as good or very good so continue
to do that we do have an interesting
thing in the venues world where we often
ask questions for people you know how
did you find today and if you lose a
rugby game the answer is terrible if
they see a show that they love yes they
love they had a great experience if they
don't like the show then we get a bad
experience so we we're not always it's
hard to say no no we're talking about
the quality of the air and the toilets
you know because it's not front of Mind
in terms of that so it is a a highly
subjective measure that we have but we
we don't have a way around it so we'll
continue to collect that
um uh but also have more in-house
operational level surveys to understand
what our clients want and need
right so I said that I was going to show
you two things that you'd ever love to
have a conversation about so they're
coming up now so the first one is and
I've written this as a problem statement
so whilst major events are the Remus of
the Great South so these are Big
festivals there's often times when
counselor our community have a desire
for us to do some community events but
Council has now dedicated in-house
resource to do so so often there's lots
of great people in this Council who who
help and do a little bit extra and we
certainly do a lot of it over there we
do a lot of delivery over there that's
actually outside of our remit because we
want to have things happen but we don't
have a cater resource
So currently we have lots of community
groups that get community funding but
they actually it's it's in the form of a
transaction of money we've got a lot of
expertise that we could offer them but
currently
um we aren't able to do so they just get
the the cash injection if you like we
also have various Council departments
with fearing capability and capacity so
that's a lot of Staff doing some great
stuff a bit of a side hustle extra and
over and above and we also of course
have a via a contract with great South
for City Center activations as well so
we've got a number of different things
available
uh the demand for Council assisted
delivery community events fall into
three categories so this is just what
we've identified we have Civic events so
that's um a death of a monarch
um this is citizenship there's all sorts
of things like that that pop up every
now and again and we go crimes we need
to do that but how do we actually
deliver it effectively safely
professionally economically
we also have engagement events we often
want to go out and actually talk to our
community and we have a great engagement
team who do all of that but often
they'll require some setup stuff and
they end up having to do extra stuff
from South setting up tables or we will
provide them with staff or a space and
we end up sort of delivering that the
the setup of that event
and then the last one is programmed
events they're the fun ones they're the
programmed events from across Council uh
where we're doing something for a
particular reason whether it be a market
day we want to activate we want to try
something at this particular Square in
town we want to have an event to
celebrate this we want to do something
for matariki all of those things are the
programming programmed events
so a solution and this will be this is
an intended ltp bed a small team a small
team could leverage existing event
project budgets to provide a more
efficient coordination and Community
Support of events in invercargill this
will increase the planning Effectiveness
timely responses to event opportunities
and increase the visible presence of
Council in the community so this is a
team of people a small team that could
coordinate resources and provide
expertise health and safety planning
work hand in hand with Community groups
who are saying hey we've got a great
event we want to do this and sometimes
they might encounter uh asking
permission from Council but it's just a
little bit too hard to navigate for a
community group about who to ask
permission for who to do this so this is
about having a resource that would
navigate through Council but also help
deliver when Council wants to do things
for itself
I uh with the cheese permission would be
a good time to stop on this one for
questions or do you want to go to the uh
no let's stop here at this point okay
for the events team Trish so do you see
this
team was developed do you see that in
outside contract I think using one of my
hats say rotary they wanted to put on a
convention in the city so they would
contract to you for awesome advice or
your team yeah look at the moment we do
that for the venue we say hey don't put
your table there sort of thing or you
need a health and safety span but yes it
would be able to provide that support
and then say actually your goals are so
well aligned to ours can we actually
activate that space and do a program
there or share the bring the library out
of the wall out of its walls and and
deliver something there so
um yeah that is exactly that it's to to
navigate Council to deliver when Council
wants to deliver and also coordinate and
put everything together there are
opportunities out there to leverage
Community capacity and actually build on
that empowerment aspect of the community
if we walk hands and hand then they can
walk alone in the future so is there
I'll come to you in a moment even is it
the opportunity then Richard to have
almost a One-Stop shop where people
would come and be looking to book an
event a venue for an event and and
realize that there are three other
Departments of council they probably
need to be talking to as well that if we
had our own events team they can bring
those departments together we've we've
talked a lot around you know
tool kits and guidance for people but
it's it's more forms and we've got to
acknowledge that not everyone in our
Council our community rather
at a level where they can search for the
information because they think that
they're fine and so yes it would be a
One-Stop shop I guess for some people
it'll also make promotion it means that
someone who applies for funding can then
say actually can you help me do I need a
traffic management plan or a health and
safety plan and it's a bit of an extra
safety step as well so yeah a bit of
both
Evelyn
it occurred to me when you were speaking
earlier Richard that one of the things
that we probably have within venues is
equipment that is underutilized is that
one of the um ways that we could be
working smarter not harder within our
community is
um
the equipment that sits there for
three weeks out of four or whatever
because there's not a particular
activity that would use it as some of
that transferable between places or is
this more location specific or a bit of
both a bit of both so at the moment
we're quite happy for other Council
departments and Council family and
certain groups to pick up our bean bags
and take them somewhere because we love
our bean bags but we're not going to let
a lighting disc do the same thing but if
we have a staff which includes an event
delivery person we say yeah we we might
be able to uh if again if you're uh
event aligns with the goals of council
yes we've got a person who can take the
equipment and actually operate it for
you within the prioritization of
resources and stuff that is possibility
yes and along the lines of the working
smarter not harder
um it's all those little touches that
make an event successful that
um a first time or inexperienced
organizer might not consider like
I don't know flowers for the lobby or
something like that those sorts of
things that actually lift yourself out
of the ordinary absolutely and so a
community group will do something in a a
little Council Reserve or something like
that and they'll design a fantastic
event but they need to be challenged and
said hey if we are parking your cars is
it a curb all the way around is there a
place that a personal wheel to use or a
walk or use or someone who's a bit less
stable can get to that event or do they
have to cross a bit of a muddy thing
it's those sorts of things that often
people are focused so much on that
Community event which might be fantastic
they don't think some of those more this
glamorous Logistics and when it comes to
less glamorous Logistics
that's the remit of council isn't it
and I guess the final thing about this
is that how does this small team pay for
itself
absolutely so
um look we've costed this and and it
needs to be uh worked through more of in
terms of the bed in terms to fully
understand it but at the point uh we're
looking at probably around about 250k
would be the size of where we're looking
um acknowledging also that we do have
pockets of budgets across so often some
will say we'll do a project and this
project has been given da da da and
within that there might be some
available uh resource to actually pay
for some of the services that's what we
don't know at this point in time there's
certainly demand
yeah and thank you Richard
um I've sort of a Christian so when I
look at this um
future events team and what it can look
like and what you can deliver to our
community one of the uncomfortable
aspects of what I've had in my mind
listening to this is that we have our
community wellbeing fund subcommittee
which people come to us and apply for
funding for different community events
we rate that of different scaling points
um I guess for me my alert is if they
decide one of the applicants to then
come along and hire your events team
um to utilize and spend Council money
for their event and we're effectively
changing money between our departments
how do you see that
um playing out in the future yeah so I
mean and this is a philosophical
Viewpoint and and hasn't been developed
in the bed but from my perspective I
would say the the venue sorry the the
production costs so the actual tangible
stuff is where that money should go what
we're talking about here is projects
would be covered within event budgets
but their Staffing would be a rateable
um uh income if you're like a um a
rational expense so that the staff we
wouldn't be charging for we would be
providing it as a service but it's the
cost of the whether they're hiring a
piece of um equipment or a venue Etc
that's what where there could be a bit
of a circular amount of money going
around
[Music]
um the interesting thing I guess from a
community perspective is the demand at
the moment has been largely from Council
within Council wanting to do activations
to reach the community to to live and
have a space provide vibrancy Etc
uh it's an untested demand from uh with
a community because I think a lot of
community enjoyed doing this delivery
and we don't want to stamp that out we
want to empower them so I think I would
see that the Interventional Council
being around advice and navigating
ourselves more for and doing stuff yes
for Council but for the community
there's much more that navigation sort
of stuff yeah otherwise we're we're just
coming in and taking over and yeah
that's not great
Alex then Tom I'm not actually I'm just
going to park there for now thank you
okay thanks Tom
I mean it seems very obvious to me that
you'd expect that such a team of such an
individual would already exist within
Council so I'm surprised that well not I
knew but I'm still less surprised that
we don't was it ever such a rule in the
past
uh not in this Incarnation as that pure
events team we've certainly had uh
pockets of individuals over over the
years doing different things in
different um incarnations there's a
perennial conversation and any sort of
government or local government about in
in-house versus Outsource and and we've
certainly had those conversations in the
past but as a dedicated team am I I'm
not aware of uh anything but there'll be
individuals who would have worked on
different projects yes and the
Australian supplementary the the team
which exists within Great South which we
subcontract to to do some of this sort
of work
um to have it is separating Within
city
um would feel immediately so there was
overlap potentially duplication
um creating work for each other between
the two teams and and therefore I wonder
wherever such a
group were based whether it was within
counselor whether it was within Great
South
um it would be better perhaps if there
was only one group rather than two
separate groups
so Michael do you want to respond to him
yeah that is kind of the question I was
going to go to anyway thank you Tom
um
there is the great self-contract sitting
there
um and what we're Contracting them for
is Central City activation component
it's ring fenced in relation to that so
there is some boundaries in relation to
that
um that contract does have a time frame
in relation to that and whether that's
in scope out of scope that's a very
valid question
um probably a question we need to look
through from timing
the other aspect I would raise is there
is a gap coming in relation to a number
of our more established events as times
going on you start to lose the event
coordinators and it's where the council
want them to continue we will get to a
stage where those events will not be
able to continue with the current event
groups does council want them to
continue
this team may need to actually take up
some of those events and actually
coordinate the community itself uh one
particular event I would raise would be
the Anzac
um
Memorial or so I think that would be one
prime example for me let's see um the
other one which we've got a rather
significant Gap in from uh Council
perspective is how do we form our own
bids in relation to really large
significant events uh particularly
around National sporting events that we
might want to put a bid in as a city we
don't have the capacity within the
organization
I would say we have the capability
across the organization just don't have
the capacity this is allowing um the
potential some dedicated resource in
that space to be available to be pulled
aside to actually do those components so
from that I think you need to think the
now the now but also what's the future
in relation to their development and
look at that opportunity around what are
we doing in relation contract review and
going forward
Alex then grunt
um thank you Mr chair
um really pleased that you raised this
Tom and again Michael's continuation
because that's what I've been bouncing
around backwards and forwards with the
voices inside my head
um
I think us um doing this I would you
know if you think of the venues and
events as a business unit on its own in
its own right it's no different to us
giving Great South funding for
the extension of services that they're
providing there but it's also no
different than the stadium and the money
the money that we provide them they have
a dedicated team
um events team there to maximize the
benefit for events at the stadium I
wouldn't say this is any different to
that we'd have a team dedicated to
community benefit and maximization of
our
um venues
except we've just you know retained it
in-house rather than Contracting it out
Grant
yeah thanks T just to clarify that
though didn't we hear before that the
funding we give to Stadium Southland and
the swimming pool and one other video
account review was to do with the
maintenance of the buildings
not the certain the service was to run
itself
is that what I picked up earlier four
Splash Palace or do we just give them a
General Grant and they use it for
whatever they like that varies from the
operation to operations so for the likes
of the pool it is purely around
maintenance for that physical but asset
yep yeah whereas the and there's a
portion of community good that supports
admission fees yeah
um but for venues like the Civic and the
Scottish Hall in the stadium that was
what the stadium Grant does it go just a
general bread or is it yeah
both both ways right okay just that was
a point so sorry my question is around
if we were going to stand up a team
Richard what's the availability skill
set
or would it be have we got that skill
set we'd just leverage off say or within
the health and safety might sort of
help in that area if there was a healthy
safety thing going to be
um that we do have capability already
within Council and the where this
um where this lands in terms of where it
logically sits yes uh we're saying the v
news team but it doesn't necessarily
have to be in the venues and Event
Services in that seems a logical place
to be able to maximize some of our
resources but also our flexible staff we
talked about those casuals before
there's a lot of capability for
delivering that the events World
um has a couple of components to it so
there's that navigation Council which is
actually a council skill set to say hey
you need to talk to this department this
person this form
Etc there's also another skill set
around programming and as you know we're
developing that programming thing the
ability to talk to a customer or design
a program we've got that again spread
out and the last one is event delivery
event delivery once it's all been
planned is around having Warm Bodies on
the street to move things to set up to
allow those other departments to do
really great events or other community
groups to do really great events there's
a skill set that is not different
particularly difficult to recruit for
um so the as in terms of Attraction and
session something like this up I think
it's completely doable cool and so then
supplementary
in terms of the there could be a
reallocation of some of the funding that
goes to Great South it could be retained
within Council to support this
um team
at the stage um in the bed we have an
identified where the money would come
from that'll be up to a prioritization
process that you'll go through with in
the debates in the ltp yeah but the
Tom's pointer would be you know seen
nonsensical to have a team over there
and a team here we'll just have one team
the only thing I'll say on on the
contract aspect we have acknowledged
both of our organizations previously
that
um from time to time we've we've we've
both felt orphaned as organizations in
terms of our delivery in this particular
aspect major events are very clearly um
sitting with great South and they're
doing a great job and they can connect
in with their knowledge around tourism
and and promote it nationally we both
acknowledge that that's when it comes
down to a smaller level there is no
home it's it's hanging around there so
we have had those conversations in the
past thank you Josh
save the end this team would be a bridge
yourself or not look what it would
provide is people who have got a job
description that is dedicated around
events that could leverage off the
expertise so as when there is a big
event coming to town that great South is
doing there would be someone who can
talk to and support and be their
interface from Council to say actually
while you're doing that we would love to
do a community activation to talk about
this or that as part of it so it would
at least open a Channel of communication
we have found in the past that
um the the speed of our organizations
are working in different directions and
different priorities at different times
of the year and having a team that's
aligned in their purpose in terms of
both loving to do events sort of thing
speaking the same name which would have
its advantages
thank you
okay can we move on to the oh sorry
knobby and then we'll move on yeah just
one just one quick reflection I guess
um we've had an in-house team before
which is a community services team down
and Leslie and others will know that
that did some event work as well
more Community activation rather than
events yeah yeah
so given that we've had some degree of
In-House already
I'd be a little bit nervous if we were
um looking to downsize the contract with
uh Great South without some
some real index consideration of what
the consequences of all this are I'm not
suggesting it should be one place or the
other
um but certainly um recent discussions
I've had with Charmy and others that
contract initially was only to have four
large events a year
and I've pushed her recently so that's
not good enough if we want to activate
the inner city has got to be more like
fortnightly or every three weeks and
you'll see they've got a schedule out to
that effect now but they are very much
generating just inner city stuff events
that predominantly use local artists or
food stores or whatever to generate it
so it's a little bit different to what
Richard's saying they could be
complementary but I'd hate the thing
we're doing one of the expense of the
other or overlapping each other yeah I'm
not sure they're generating them I think
they're going along and assisting the
people who are who's that
Great Sound
well I mean if you look at this speaking
as one of those people we've got we've
got that later on we've got some
scheduling later on one of their
activity reports and two of them involve
food stalls and eat food eating events
and things and they have the things that
I've promoted with them recently that
they're easy to do things to generate
some uh activity in these three in
particular
other points just don't just point
Clarity clarification on this this could
work in a complementary way to that
contract actually what we're talking
about here is the the generation of
events from this Council that haven't
had a home we know that at the moment we
do have a home for City Center
activations but the demand to date has
been for the other things around that
outside of the city center that Council
wants to celebrate and so this is an end
and conversation not specifically around
that particular contract
and I did like um Richard's analogy that
you know if the feedback was you felt
terrible after we lost a rugby game we
could knock over rug repair tomorrow
couldn't we
not as long as if somebody goes to a
show that they don't like that doesn't
look good
[Laughter]
don't win too many rugby games
I don't know we've had a few of those
games over the years and it's still
there yeah
part of our character Richard you want
to move on to the second Point thank you
okay so the second thing we're here to
discuss is and and this has come from
your feedback previously a community
Sport and recreation facility strategy
so trying to craft a bit of a problem
statement here so Council support and
provision of community facilities that
service local and Regional users has in
the past been led by opportunity crisis
and ad hoc advocacy from groups
historically decisions have been
reactive and without an overall strategy
of for investment and revision to guide
them
so without a clear data-driven approach
to investment there exists a risk of
inequity across the different groups and
sectors of the community so how do we
know that we're giving enough love to
this part of the community to the
sporting code Etc there exists a risk of
decision paralysis due to a lack of
information to enable prioritization and
a risk of missed opportunities and
strategic co-investment optimization and
value impact for ratepayer money we know
we've had some really difficult
conversations about how to prioritize
work on facilities and sometimes it's
because we're having conversations and
we just don't quite have
a scientific Bible to to just reach to
and provide us guidance and a bit of a
this is the The View so here are some of
the things that
we think we believe in so the current
situation facility investment has
sometimes been reactive and emotive
squeaky wheel stuff and that's that's
the world in which we live sometimes
things happen in community or in or in
cities where we need to be quick to
react to save a provision or something
Etc
uh we have a desire to encourage social
cohesion we've talked a lot about that
today and providing places for people to
recreate together we want to avoid
duplication and provision we don't want
to spend a whole lot of money in making
decision and then discover that we're
actually there's another provision
that's the same thing elsewhere we don't
want cronyism we will and we don't want
the perception of cronyism so we want to
be able to defend our decisions to the
community and say why we've made that
decision what the benefits what the
disbenefits were and have that recorded
in advance as we can have those quality
debates
we let data around need future growth
and provision statements for facilities
a provision statement says how many
swimming pools do you need or rugby
stadiums or Community pocket Parks do
you need
um as a population based is it how far
you need to travel to one of those
services
we want vibrancy and the right fit for
purpose facilities that attract people
to invercargill and we want iconic
venues that build civic pride
we also need well-maintained facilities
that are safe well used and loved by the
community we want to also unlock
opportunities that eliminate waste and
provide value for rate payers
so we need a pragmatic action orientated
data-rich strategy which with a specific
with a specific implementation plan to
enable confident and just end time
decision makings now the first reaction
from people in the room might be oh gosh
is this another another plan or strategy
that sits on the shelf and that's why we
want to say that we want to approach but
we also want an action plan that
determines where we are going to focus
our attention into it's a possible
solution is a facility strategy
it's a project to understand the
existing provision and the future needs
of community Sport and Recreation
facilities to guide decision making on
strategic investments in the future we
want to understand what's needed here
and now and what's likely to be needed
in 20 years time and where it would
likely be needed
so stage one of the project would Define
the current and future needs and the
approaches for determining
prioritization how do we react when
someone comes to us with a proposal and
a need how do we know that that how do
we since check it fact check it how do
we combine and understand what the
provision of other funders are in the
city
the second stage was an implementation
plan identifying specific actions and
opportunities for co-investment
feasibility and prioritization to enable
fit for purpose Community facility in
sport and Recreation provision aligned
to the needs and the growth of the
community
now what we're talking about isn't a
plan that's so rigid that you cannot
deviate because life's not like that
this is about having an approach and an
ability to have those prioritization
conversations and with that I know
you're itching to drill me so with the
chairs permission open the questions
thanks Richard can I just kick off with
this follows on from active South and
spaces and places strategies that that
they've looked at and and I think that
you're right and look Grant and I have
been proving to some of the discussions
that have fed into this that we have
been
reactionary uh in in looking at
repairing things that are become
dilapidated
um and perhaps
we're not forward planning and this is
what having a strategy is is going to
offer and that it's probably going to
for an initial investment mean better
value for money
um following on from that Steve
yeah thank you um thanks Mr chair um
like I'll take this question
um because I've been working on the
spaces and places strategy with active
Southland and this is one of the
objectives that that review has
identified that at a regional level
we've got a really good spaces and
places plan for the regional provision
but where it's
um where I think our learning is that
it's failed to actually get into the
local territory
um discussion about where communities
need to invest and the primary investor
in the large majority of those
facilities are councils and so one of
the objectives out of the new strategy
is for councils to develop their own
plan as an implementation and as a
response to the regional strategy so
this doesn't duplicate
and it doesn't compete with it uses the
same framework and decision-making
approach that the regional plan does but
it brings it down to a local level and
enables localized decisions to be made
and that's where it sits around this
table
thanks Alex thank you will it be built
um from the data and insights
um I guess information that Excel has
been Gathering absolutely effectively
yeah at the last in part um I think what
we've done and what Richard's also
identifying and this has been identified
through multiple presentations today is
that we do as a as a sector in sport
Recreation and Leisure there is a big
data deficit to informed decision making
and this is one of the things that would
plug in that data around participation
around usage around condition and
quality and so that would be the first
step in that strategy for us is to
understand as a community what are we
sitting on and what do we need going
forward
and to that we often have been led by an
existing provision debate so we've got a
site with something on it so they were
always talking about how do we improve
it how do we meet the community needs
have we ever stepped back and said
actually if we re if we reevaluated it
it's not near a bus stop so do we need
to change our transport provision as we
already discussed before or should we be
looking at another site and actually
optimizing that selling that piece of
land and actually building something
over here which is closer to public
communities is allowing for two
Community groups to use it or do
different codes Etc it's those sorts of
things
um look yeah I'm
a pretty a very big fan of us being
really strategic in this space
um and if you look at air Capital spend
that's in a long-term plan there's a lot
of money that's being spent there end
you know
some degree of apprehension around is
this the right spend and I think that's
something we would need to be really
cognizant for because that's right for
money the second thing is that we're
very fortunate in this community to have
significant
um Community
um organizations like ilt and then the
Community Trust that are big investors
in our community and in these types of
things we need to provide direction for
them and I think they're looking for
that direction because you know any one
of those people will tell you that their
dollar is getting asked to be spread
further and further so they want to be
very strategic and be able to you know
invest in facilities that do meet a lot
of the needs that we cover off in our
social well-being and economic
well-being all those their full
well-being so you know I think there's a
real strong need for this and for this
Council to show some really strong
leadership with them this space in their
Community to get a really great outcome
over 30 50 years
so I'm a big supporter of this approach
I'll be yeah and just to reinforce what
Grant's saying um so it seems to me I've
only been here 48 years
um that we tend to traditionally uh back
up the sports so good example is uh
soccer's got far more numbers especially
in the youth space than rugby has
Rugby's pretty well a dying sport and I
know people Peter won't like me saying
that but the numbers are dropping off
significantly yet we continue to pour a
whole lot of money into rugby park
and if you look forward well how many
around the table know what's happening
in the beach volleyball space down that
we've created how many how many people
are going there we don't know well we
haven't found out recreational cycling's
huge
um you know when you look at senior
soccer and you look at they playing a
Target South and competition for example
and that's the leading sport for junior
sports kids playing soccer as 30 or 40
people attain attend a game down at
Terminal Thompson once a fortnight it's
just not there and yet you'll see them
on the activity reports later on this
afternoon that the people out walking
dogs at Sandy Point on the old golf
course 6 000 people in seven weeks so
you know we've lost sight I think of
what we should be providing for our
community the big franchises
uh rugby netball indoor basketball
should be all funded by the the big
stakeholders are there we should be
looking for a much more input into
activity going forward and the big one
that's on the horizon whether we like or
not is Esports I'm not sure how they
playing a computer is actually called a
sport but it is
yes I know damn we've had this Obsession
but look there's some there's some
fantastic competition
I understand that and it's huge if you
talk to James who some of us have had
some input with you'll know the numbers
are around and look there's some really
change of conventional thinking I've
just about got the workman's Club Over
The Line
to provide one of those rooms upstairs
one or three rooms and put somewhere
between 80 and 100 computers in there
permanently so that we can have a an
Esports venue and also looking to South
City for the same sort of capacity as
well because that's where the activity
is coming forward it's not it's not in
rugby and soccer
and hockey and stuff like that I mean we
need to maintain those but we've I think
as grandma said we've got to have a
forward look for the next 10 20 years
thank you Tom
yeah I'm not a big fan of central
planning you just begun to get it wrong
um as nobby's just said uh you know
times change Sports change
um if you believe that we can back a
winner
in 2023 say with a plan for there's
going to be X rugby stadiums there's
going to be so much Circle space so much
for cycling you can guarantee within 10
years that sort of changed
um I I think I think if if we have a
plan it should be to be flexible I think
we if we have a
um you know a central plan should be to
create spaces which are flexible so that
they conserve a range you see so that as
times change and kids decide that they
don't want to play they do want a place
um beach volleyball rather than soccer
but that space can be changed to suit
that Richard that's absolutely right so
that's why it's got two two things out
there a strategy and a plan so the
strategy defines the approach about how
you would uh delve into the data but the
plan would need to be
um continually refreshed you'd have a
prioritization list but those
prioritizations would change depending
on the opportunity
um the new structure of the uh
Commonwealth Games for example allowing
for multiple cities and activations
might change the prioritization of that
it also might Define things like what is
a destination facility versus a local
facility do we fit out a local facility
in a different way to a destination
facility there might be rules around
what when we invest it must be
multi-purpose it must be or at a certain
level it can be more specific with
bespoke equipment it's those kind of
things that we we want so as when we
still and there's still a place for
debate and there's still a place for
prioritization and Community
responsiveness but as we're doing that
we've got a structure to do it around
that is considered and provides us a bit
of confidence in our decision making
Evelyn
yeah so I'm a little bit straddling
about this because I think
that one of the things
it worries me if we look at amalgamation
or
promoting a particular facility what
happens to those places that have been
doing
those things for a long time
um I mean there could be clubs that
offer
I don't know I'll say something and
it'll be wrong
um but they're happily they have a club
facility that does a particular activity
and all of a sudden the city puts money
into something that offers that activity
as part of what they do as well what
happens to their facility and do we run
the risk of downgrading some of those
things
um this is a sort of competition
um
and I I think about
um for instance
we had
Central polls and we built Cold Stream
and then we built Splash Palace and
there's no Cold Stream there's no
Central Pool either there's just the one
poll all our eggs are in one basket so
to speak
but then we've got we've had other
things like
um and forgive me I'm not a sports
person so I'm going to get this wrong
but I believe that some of the
um squash clubs were actually
co-located with other facilities
you build
um the stadium you put your squash Club
in there or squashed Quartz in there
what does that do to those other local
club-based facilities does are they able
to carry on or does it undermine them
and I think it is a council
when we're planning these things maybe
that's something that we need to be
aware of because those local Hub things
are as important
for that Community even if they're not
the fleshist or the you know most
up-to-date
I'm not sure what the answer is yeah
because Cold Stream went because boys
highly wanted their land back indeed and
squash are actually located nonslow
street that just happened to be courts
of the stadium right but the work hubs
that had
um their own squash courts Once Upon a
Time have they all gone the way of all
good things because they've been
centralized and I just wonder what our
role is in and all of that is it to
um gather things Under One Roof because
this cost Effectiveness in it or should
we be looking at supporting people where
they are can I can I respond yeah a
couple of things I think what Richard
said around you know there's two aspects
the strategy and planning and certainly
I don't think there's any ever taught to
go and plan centrally you know what the
city looks like around facility and the
Squash one's actually a really good
example because I know when they looked
at their transition squashed South and
were heavily involved in what squash
looked like in provision and they've
actually got a great outcome when they
have big competitions they use down at
Lonzo Street primarily but if you look
at how the squash courts are activated
though
um
Stadium they're very casual in their use
but equally they're involved in
competition so that's a great example
in my mind any of what you'd be looking
to do you work with your sport to
developer
plan for them they develop the airplane
but it fits into the strategy and that's
I think what we're trying to achieve
here we're sort of taking the helicopter
View and then working with the sports to
say well what does your plan for your
sport in 10 20 30 years look like in 30
years I know it's a long time but what
are they trying to achieve they will
probably try to say more participation
all those sorts of things right that's
for them to solve but we've got to take
account of that when we develop our
strategy and I think that's the piece
that's missing but it's a good example
around here it was done in squash in the
stadium
Korea
um things which bring this to us I yes
to support what garage just said one of
the areas on how to Future proof or how
are we going to use our facilities to
best have
the future mapped out a lot of the
national bodies to all our sporting
groups have some pretty amazing data
that is very futuristic it has a rate of
what diminishing players they have
versus the reasons why so the
information is actually already out
there so I guess what I'm saying is how
do we take advantage of that and utilize
it to how we can predict how our
facilities can be in the future so
that's what I'm thinking this is we'll
be going right yeah and this is about
linking everyone out so first of all we
don't want to fix what ain't broke if we
don't invest in things that are already
taken away in the community groups happy
but what we might want to do is
strengthen those Community groups by
having a Premiere if we decide that
let's use squash because we're talking
about squash no promises but let's just
say we decide to make a premier location
for squash that actually promotes and
encourages national competition then
therefore we're actually supporting
those local groups because you're giving
interest people I want to take that up
and they've got a a bit of a goal to
where they end up but what it might mean
from a council perspective as we say
actually that destination facility
requires this level of service this
level of a surface rather this level of
course this level of change from
provision and therefore we might say
actually at a local level we only do
this level of surface and rather than
having continual pictures come from all
these different clubs saying well we
want what they've got and then we can
respond to say actually in our strategy
and our plan we have one destination
facility and we maintain those others
just like you've always got but if you
want to have your Premier competition
you come here it's it's those sorts of
data and we want to build on what the
national Trends are saying as well as
linking into that national competition
that promotional excelling and likes
okay thanks for the feedback uh thank
you Richard well-spoken Jason
thank you
your report your support was appreciated
there I'll uh pause the live stream
there we will reconvene at five past one
just wait on a second Council this is
the live you let me know when we're the
right
thanks skill
uh welcome back to the ltp workshop for
asset and activity plans as we look
ahead to what we're going to be
Consulting on next year
um and we move now into the art and
culture section Wayne welcome along
thank you for sitting through the last
session with us thank you Mr chair you
have the clicker thank you very much so
the overview of the activity of the Arts
culture and Heritage area of council
it's primarily focused on invercargill
City but we have tentacles and
relationships that move throughout the
wider Southland region given the nature
of collections but also some of the
partners that we are involved with so at
the moment we have relationships
obviously with the Southern Museum and
art gallery uh trust invercargill public
art gallery hey wakatuia is the
transitional space Bluff Maritime Museum
trust which is actually a CCO and the
Southland Regional Heritage committee
through those Partners we're increasing
our community engagement access to the
collection but also our participation
um in making our collection accessible
what are all what all boils down to is
actually celebrating
invercargill and Southland through the
concept of the story of Southland which
is a high-level research document was
which was done in the early 2000s that
continues to be reviewed and also
updated
uh the Strategic priorities for us
um obviously we fit uh in all of the
Strategic priorities ensuring uh once
and for all that we're there celebrating
the the story of Southland in our future
focused economy we actually look to the
past to see what Innovation and
opportunities can form part of the story
of Southland for the future so if we
think about the past and we think of of
people like godwood who put that twist
in The Hairpin or straying across the
road who invented instant coffee Burns
Watson who came up with the Rosland
reviver for lambs we had Burt Monroe who
everybody knows about and today in our
contemporary World Peter Bick
um so we're actually very rich in terms
of
yeah history
um can actually support us as a future
focused economy by actually showing the
Innovation that we've seen and
celebrating the Innovation that we've
seen uh in the past going into the
present and the future
our current annual budget we're working
at the moment with 11 uh full-time
equivalents those people are primarily
working on the pickup and relocation of
the Southern Museum and art gallery
trust collection we acknowledge that
once uh Tisbury and also project 1225
are on board but that head count uh will
creep somewhere in the vicinity of
around 25 uh people so that is part of
our planning that we're looking at for
the future
um uh rates at the moment we have
obviously the general rates Revenue
which comes in on that is distributed in
a number of areas which includes the
operation of
haywakatuya the other rates Revenue
includes the significant contribution
from the Southland Regional Heritage
committee towards the operation of the
Southland Museum and art gallery
is that the 1.3 million sorry before you
leave that slide so I can go back to
that slide yes that's the 1.3 uh million
comes from Southern Regional Heritage
committee and who did he get the money
so the Southern Regional Heritage
committee has the ability to rate based
on properties and invercargill City
Southland District Council and Gore
District Council
which we collect all goes into a one
large pot and then is distributed uh
Southland Museum Gore for the operation
of of East and Southland and Bluff
Maritime Museum and to heckaway receive
some plans from that on top of that
there is an amount of money that
supports project Arc as well as other uh
projects which occur
distributed
no it's not it's uh distributed
basically on a per needs basis
um and at the moment the funding model
is currently under review by the
Southland Regional Heritage committee
um for example Bluff Maritime Museum in
tahekohe both receive just over thirteen
thousand dollars per annum the model was
established around 2005 and it's now
time inappropriate that the model is
actually reviewed thank you
sorry can I just have to further
question but I don't realize it was
coming through that way so
can we ask for more money in any one
year
um we can always for that we're not
Regional we can always seek additional
funding from the regional Heritage
committee but it'll be based on a
project right um and so an example of
that would be that uh Southern Museum
and art gallery
um and ICC purchased a freezer so that
we can actually undertake uh the
fumigation of of objects which have Oro
or something else in them that was
funded through the Southland Regional
Heritage Academy in addition to the
money that we receive
um
my apologies I got overly excited there
um maintaining our core level of service
so at the moment uh we have some
operational delivery uh hey wakatuia we
have a management contract actually in
place at the moment with the
invercargill public art gallery there is
a contract for Management Services
between the Southland Museum and art
gallery trust and invercargill city
council and also we have a contribution
towards the Southland Regional Heritage
joint committee their contribution uh
takes a number of forms firstly there is
the direct Financial contribution to the
regional Heritage committee through our
ratepayer base secondly we have
councilors sitting on that committee
councilor sopa is currently the deputy
chair we're also represented by
monofinoa by Reverend cook
and on top of that we provide one of the
three advisors to the regional Heritage
committee at present we're also looking
after the project Arc contract for the
next two years so we have that staff
those staff members as part of our our
team and they are providing services at
the moment for the relocation of the
museum collection but once that
collection has been relocated that is an
opportunity to work with other
institutions around the invercargill and
wider Southland area does anybody not
know what project Arc is
excellent answer thank you great thank
you Mr chia
we have some uh compliance uh
requirements so the biggest requirement
that everybody will always hear about is
maintaining appropriate temperature
humidity and security to look after our
collection that's effectively seen as a
as a bit of a no-brainer however our
biggest challenge is compliance with
legislation and and changing legislation
so
as some members may be aware as
counselors may be aware recently the
arms act has been reviewed and uh there
is new
um
requirements specifically for museums
which have been introduced uh this month
we're currently working with New Zealand
Police and ensuring that we meet all the
requirements of the New Zealand arms act
likewise we have the protected objects
act that covers
uh many of the items that we hold in our
collection the wildlife act which um
actually deals with a lot of the stuffed
birds and and various other animals that
we hold as part of our collection
because even though they may no longer
exist they may be extinct they're still
covered by uh legislation from the
parliament uh we also have to be
cognizant of the trade and Endangered
Species Act that means that if
somebody's coming in and offering us for
example various ivories or stuff like
that we're just aware of asking the
right questions about their backgrounds
there are some other areas that we do
have to be involved with Interpol stolen
works of art always an interesting thing
to suddenly look at but we're now we are
now dealing with a world which is post
the World War II
um soldiers many of those soldiers have
now passed away their families have
suddenly inherited some rather
interesting paintings interesting works
of art souvenirs for want of another
word that they have picked up in various
parts of the world and with the
international work that's being done at
the moment sometimes there are some
questions that are raised so we're very
cognizant of that as well as other acts
as they relate to the repatriation of
some some quite important materials
there are we have identified this year
are some opportunities for cost savings
I'm sorry it's not a lot
um we need almost every cent of our
budget to ensure that we relocate The
Collection appropriately we have some
operational cost savings uh primarily
through uh Consulting but also the
ongoing purchase of materials because we
have achieved that we have also
identified however that we can start to
generate some Revenue so we have an
opportunity with exhibition Partners uh
sponsors coming on board and with um
us now looking at the development of a
Vernon browser module that's suddenly
going to mean that our collections will
be coming online which gives us an
opportunity through for example some of
the photographic areas to generate some
income and revenue through through sales
our proposals for new or lifted levels
of services so
as counselors are aware
we're in the exciting countdown phase
for the Tisbury Reserve Regional storage
facility
to become accessible to us to relocate
The Collection to
at the moment we are estimating that our
public research area will be opened in
late 2024 that will allow members of the
public to come in and access some of the
archives but also some of the collection
directly that will be arranged initially
via appointment
um the exciting thing for us is the
Vernon system browser module we have a
very good database that database has
been audited for the first time since
the 1940s
comprehensively so we actually
understand what's in the collection
to date we have digitized over 25
000 images and so by utilizing the
Vernon system browser module which is an
add-on to the collection management
system we use we will make this material
widely available in early 2024 so we're
aiming to get the first 25 000 out
that's going to be a huge help to our
young people in our communities
especially with the new history
curriculum coming online so to be able
to access those old photographs of
invercargill and Southland that's a big
tick for for everybody it also means
that it's a chance for us to to be
re-familiarize ourselves with the
collections
during uh 2024-2025
um we're going to start a survey of our
archive collection
um and start an assessment against the
information and Records management
standard there are some very
um uh well there are national standards
that we can Benchmark ourselves uh
against however we need to have a
comprehensive understanding of what is
in our archive collection
um some of those archives in fact may
end up being returned to invercargill
city council because over the years
various things have made its way into
our collection which may not be
appropriate for us to actually hold as
as part of our collection so part of the
conversations that we'll have will
actually be rationalizing that and
ensuring that for researchers in
particular there is a One-Stop shop to
go to and they're not having to go to a
number of different places
so in addition to that I think we're all
excited about the regional storage
facility but more excited about project
1225 so there will be an increased
levels of service which will accompany
both projects so in terms of the Tisbury
facility obviously we have collection
access there is an opportunity for
education so alphabet Collection comes
some remarkable education opportunities
for for our wider Community we have a
number of regional services that we will
provide through that facility we have a
conservation lab which has been
developed as part of it we also have the
ability to develop exhibitions and
delivery through not only hey wakattuia
but also within the wider region as well
so we're actually providing access to
that collection getting it out making it
available and actually having the people
of of our region start to reconnect with
the collection action that hasn't been
really accessible since 218. likewise
with project 1225 everybody is pretty
excited about what we're going to come
up with not only in terms of the
building but also in terms of exhibition
development and delivery so some of
those measures we're going to look at
will be the cost per visit so we've put
a benchmark targeting that we'll be
looking at looking at increasing the
level of events that occur within the
building and once again that access to
education and one of the areas that is
really important to remember when it
comes to education is it's not just kids
age 5 through to 18 at school education
is all ages and so none of us ever stop
learning we all say that on a regular
basis so our Mantra in terms of
education is simply when you leave you
will know something more than when you
walked in the door and you will have
learned something
do you mean actually an entry fee
[Music]
um no what what what we're looking at
um is in terms of the cost per visit so
some of the work that we're going to end
up doing will be looking at the
operational costs we'll be looking at
the number of people who come through
there will be some uh exhibitions uh
some traveling exhibitions for example
where there may be a charge to go
through which happens in a number of of
other places
um but generally the the level of
thought to date has been that will be
free access and free entry
um however it's now widely acknowledged
that within museums there are things
um that people are very willing and
prepared to to pay for the add-ons which
are not businesses as usual
um so that's that's where we're looking
at on the cost per visit analysis
um it's it's looking perhaps in terms of
the cost so if for example
um it's costing us a million dollars a
year to operate and we've got 200 000
people going through there's there's
that element of cost obviously to to the
ratepayer that we have to be cognizant
of
um we also need to look at the revenue
opportunities as part of that
um uh cost structure so through retail
and obviously through Cafe
exhibitions and also ongoing sponsorship
can we just get through to the end of
the slides and we'll come back for
questions
um there's also some other options that
uh we're seeking some advice from
Council to consider so what moment as
counselors are aware we have a
transitional space
um at haywakatuia where it's art plus uh
Museum so we're seeking to continue that
delivery of service at the transitional
space while assessing options for a more
permanent site and as councilors are
aware there has been some discussion
about finding a more permanent site for
for that area to to be relocated to the
ACI at the moment uh within our plans
it's currently to be delivered in year
10 of the new ltp
um with budget scope to be determined in
years one and years and years two of the
new ltp as well
in terms of measuring performance
um
Arts culture and Heritage we provide a
different level of Engagement with our
community and
um it's a it's a a level of interaction
at a number of
um
uh ages it can break through all
socio-economic barriers
um this is about opportunities for for
people to have access not only to their
stories but also our stories
um we have a number of kpis that uh
we're looking at so
um in terms of
um hey wakatuia it is obviously the
number of visits we currently have
through the door a customer satisfaction
rating which will be conducted
internally and also a new kpi which we
are introducing is the number of on-site
and off-site exhibitions which celebrate
our collections meaning both the
Southern Museum and art gallery iPad but
also other institutions and also the
story of Southland because it's really
important that we have that ability to
measure that and also show that we're
demonstrating that that level of access
to our wider community
in terms of the Tisbury Regional storage
facility once again we're looking at the
number of excess visits recording that
so that means if you're coming in to
make an inquiry we're recording that
information the number of collection
items accessible to the public of both
in a physical as well as a digital uh
form something that's very new and
exciting is uh the opportunity to create
three educational resources per annum
our schools are screaming out for
educational resources which reflect our
collections our stories so this is a
great opportunity in terms of
Partnerships to be able to make this
more accessible
likewise School visits on on site
community outreach we're looking forward
to our first group of Weavers coming
through the door to be able to see
kurawai or other weaving that we hold in
our collection actually spread out for
the first time and not sitting in a box
and having to very carefully look at the
top of a cut away but actually able to
look underneath and actually see the
weaving which is something that the
Weavers know but in many cases museums
often show the top but they never show
the bottom which is the most important
thing and likewise Regional services so
we have a number of museums galleries
cultural organizations Mirai within our
wider region
we need to ensure that we are providing
a level of support in terms of the
assistance that we have through for
example project dark or also through the
conservation lab or even making material
available from the collection
in terms of project 1225 we've got a
good Benchmark up there 200 000 visitors
per annum should be our Benchmark that
is the old Benchmark for the former
Southland Museum and art gallery you
managed to exceed it every year so let's
start off with a figure which is
um
uh there and and known about in terms of
exhibitions we will be developing a
project 1225 impact model and the impact
model will very carefully consider
Revenue Generation all of those
financial as well as public private good
as well as the full well-beings and they
will then come together to actually look
at the number of exhibitions which meet
or exceed those impact objectives per
annum
um similarly adult visitors surveying
visitors on site and seeing uh those who
are satisfied to extremely satisfied and
also once again the the number of events
um to be held at project 1225 so we know
that it's a new facility we know that
people will be desperate to hold a
number of events whether it's
um
a recital theater it could be even to
the extreme of a a wedding or a
christening which are known to happen in
museums around New Zealand
um I'll rephrase that I've just had the
look uh a naming ceremony
as opposed to a christening so
um there are obviously those type of
opportunities which which can occur
thank you Mr chair that's the
presentation
Peter then Trish
Wayne what would be the most valuable
piece that you have in the museum or
pieces and do you insure them
um while we have a large number of
pieces which which have uh considerable
value
um and primarily those collections uh
are within the tokamori within our Maori
collection
um because they are completely
Irreplaceable at the moment there is a
blanket cover of just over 10 million
dollars for uh the collection which is
um uh available through the annual
report thank you as we had to explain to
um Auditors every year is hard to Value
priceless
Trish two things for each year first one
the resources that you're going to
develop as part of the measuring
performance of the facility will you
work um in conjunction with nitahu for
that because they have developed some
amazing history resources for this area
um we're very fortunate through the ewe
committee and our relationship with the
uh fortunaka that they would be part of
the the conversation we would be
um silly to go anywhere else and So that
obviously gives us that um connection
through to uh my tahu and some of the
resources there are also some other
stories that haven't had that
opportunity to be developed to date this
is a great opportunity it's just that
they are very yes and the other thing is
will we be able to have for you chair
perhaps a discussion about cost of the
museum in some stage you know cost going
into the museum and into activities and
things we haven't had a discussion about
them whether or not we charge yes that
is a decision that Council will make at
some point yes
primarily for people who are not our
rate players yeah
yeah so
grunt
yeah thanks chair um the Tisbury
facility what user pays
how does that
play a part in that facility will people
pay to use that facility like if schools
want to access
um
resources to support curriculum will
there be a charge to the at the moment
there was no plan to put a charge on for
that we don't have a charge at the
public library at the moment for schools
accessing the resources of the public
library so if that was a decision to be
made by Council it would have to cover
obviously a number of council sites
okay
just within the digitizing and the
greater freedom of accessibility
are there some things that will only
have limited accessibility for instance
I'm
I'm struggling to to remember if I've
even asked you this but do we have any
material that relates to tourist
straight Islanders and and tongue to
takitaki for instance who have
restrictions about
um images of their uh ancestors being
displayed
we've not asked for
necessarily that particular restriction
but we have asked to have some control
over who does access some of of our
images so I guess that it would be fair
to say that we should have those same
policies set apply to other indigenous
peoples
um for you Mr chair yes the the is the
simplest answer
um there would be no uh putting up of
any images which had not been signed off
especially as it relates to
um Australian Aboriginal and Torres
Strait Islanders in particular
um but we're also aware within um at the
moment within the Pacifica Community
there's some ongoing debate and
discussion
um that is where we have an opportunity
working closely locally with P act but
also with the wider uh Pacifica
community and our colleagues in museums
and Samoa and the Cook Islands that we
can actually start to work together to
to find appropriate ways to to advertise
and also display some of this material
that we do hold we do hold
um
Australian Aboriginal and Torres Strait
Island material within our collection we
are very fortunate that most of that
material that we hold is not generically
named it actually has a location that it
has come from so we know in effect with
the work currently being led by te Papa
that we will in fact end up with a
long-term relationship with a number of
different peoples around Australia
and the other thing that I had was when
you were talking about
um
the exhibitions or as such or the
material being
you know I'm trying to be careful here
because it's actually not your
collection well it's your collection but
not so the museum can't just say to
people you can have this or that because
there are collections within the
collections that have rules around them
but are you talking about things like
what we are showing within the Civic
Chambers for example
um within the Civic buildings from the
city's collection is that the sort of
opportunities that you'll be advancing
in the future or
the use of the South and Art Foundation
collection in other places and spaces
rather than just in
um
yeah
herokatory or any other specific
building so there are always a number of
opportunities with with collections
depending on how robust those
collections are and so any loan which
comes in
um we have to go through a quite a
strict process before we actually agree
to make those loans available but the
most important thing is trying to make
material available but ensuring the that
that particular material is preserved
and looked after in the way that it's
it's loan so it's not a free-for-all
it's not a shopping expedition but what
it is is a way that we can carefully
curate some material to make it
available in the in the wider community
and in the interests of equity I'll ask
you the same question that I asked
Richard and that's about the
digitization and the cross
the ability to cross communicate between
library and Museum collection and all
those sorts of things and the steps that
you're taking to ensure that because for
instance does the library use Vernon and
so with us adding to with Vernon access
is that going to make it harder or
easier for that cross fertilization
um one of the challenges that we do have
is the uniqueness of the systems for
example with the library but also with
the council archive system and our own
system what we have been exploring in
terms of conversations is bringing those
parts of the knitting together in one
Central platform so we have a pretty
smart IT team at ICC and the Brilliance
is going to come to the fore as we're
able to take all of these little bits
one day and see it come through within a
a single platform however in the interim
we're having we are developing our own
With a View to a long-term opportunity
to bring that together on a single
platform we looked at a number of
options over the last 18 months and we
found that there were voyables within
those options so we're continuing that
conversation
thank you
thank you other questions
if not thank you this afternoon
Patricia
Welcome to our hot seats
I'll do the important part of the slides
we've had a morning of dreams and
sparkles and unfortunately now we talk
about investment property well the
Investments the investment activity
so just a reminder the investment
activity is actually more than just the
investment property
it also includes our investment in ichl
and the other ccos that we held directly
and our treasury activity activities so
this is a borrow F borrowing and we do
have one asset loan at the moment to ICL
so this is actually if you want to flip
to the next slide
this is actually probably a slightly
different activity to everyone else's
but we still
tied back into the Strategic priorities
and Community outcomes so the whole role
of this activity is to make money
this is the activity that puts money
back in and reduces the rates so we've
got the current budget up there for the
current Financial year
and it's just easier to separate into
its two components so the treasury
activity at the moment
has about a
5.2 million dollar net positive game
to the bottom line
so that's really just an interest and
dividends and the investment property
is sitting at
about a hundred thousand dollars
positive
if we look at operational
there is no staff immediately
there's no staff tagged to these at this
activity
um the finance team manage the treasury
and the property team manage the
investment property so it's those costs
are sitting in those other activities so
it does inflate its performance just a
little but it is necessary to keep it
out to keep that visibility on what is a
essentially an income generating
activity
so
in maintaining a levels of service
we'll sort of look at each part and
separate so we want to maintain the
levels and service around our investment
property portfolio we have got a mixture
of income producing and in those
strategic and Community assets sitting
in there at present
and that's understanding that mix
um as a council and working about
whether we have that right mix there and
whether some of those strategic and
Community assets would be better
elsewhere within Council and not sitting
within the investment activity
the other really important one is to
maximize the return and make sure we
have that steady returned from ichl
so that we know we've always got that
base thing and to minimize the cost of
borrowing
it's not minimizing borrowing it's
minimizing the cost of it by using a
treasury tools that we have available to
make sure that we
at going through Peaks and interest
rates we've managed to minimize where
possible through using fishery
instruments
however we do have a couple of
compliance requirements
and this is where there is a bid or it's
an option for you as well and that's in
relation to one of our investment
properties so one of the investment
properties we still have some property
down at Arrow and that's the homestead
itself which at the present we cannot
lease as a residential list because it
doesn't meet the healthy homes criteria
and so we would need to invest some
money if that was and then I will bring
that come back as an option so that's
where some of their properties we've got
the requirements of healthy homes or
just normal building ownership
things that we need to make make
um
opportunities for cost savings or
additional Revenue probably more
additional Revenue in this one
um the most obvious one is Market
rentals are on their investment
properties and we're already doing that
um
what I just mentioned is about
transferring some of those strategic
properties out of the Investment
Portfolio so these are the ones that
currently aren't
earning Market income
so they can be better managed for other
community incomes outcomes sorry
and whether we have the right investment
return
are we getting enough for my CHL
and
should we be managing our investment
property portfolio for commercial
returns only so that's
a real question that or opposes into the
role of the investment activity
we're not proposing to do anything new
or lift any levels of service here this
is pretty much a proposal to keep a
status quo type proposal
old one
other options for the council to
consider is whether we want to continue
to offer the error Homestead as a
residential lease
that's one of the options being put
forward if we do that will come with a
dollar tag
to remember how much we had within the
region of a hundred thousand
is required to uplift that property what
do we release it for
so it's a residential it's the it's the
original Homestead as part of the
Heritage German German Heritage area
um and it's for residential purposes so
so if we raised alone to do that work to
bring it up to a healthy standard
as the rental income going to
potentially enable us enable us to pay
off that loan so all the
rentals at Aurora City are three German
Cottages as well they're all at Market
rates
doesn't necessarily answer the question
I can't answer the question it would
take a long time it will take a while
right yeah so yes but slowly yes but for
us how much rental do we generate per
annum off those I couldn't tell you off
the top of my head sorry
yeah they're not
the German Cottages are not substantial
buildings they are historically
significant but I guess that's a
discussion for us to have thank you and
the courses are like just
that's getting that mixture is having
the mixture in that in the portfolio
that's probably the thing that we need
to consider around the investment
property portfolio it's just how much of
what we have in there
um
however we want to do some significant
changes around the measuring of
performance
I think
um we are proposing a lot more kpis than
what we've previously had
um we have always had the occupancy
level greater than 95 for investment
property but what we're proposing is two
new
measures in relation to what's the
return
um we're proposing to do them is on a
total portfolio basis but then on the
commercial by portfolio side as well so
that we can get a better understanding
of just that return so that that gives
the public the direct optic
and if you flip for the next slide gives
the treasury side
and I think there is nothing at present
there is no kpis at present for this
part of the activity so we're proposing
two new ones
um
very simple at this point in time till
we understand what the board looks like
that's simply the net interest income is
higher than what we had budgeted and the
dividend income is in line with budget
so that shows that we're getting what we
wanted out of
um the Holdings Group
and that our interest is being managed
in line
the expectation around dividend though
is always one of those interesting
arguments where quite often Council has
expected
an amount of dividend a fixed amount
whereas a dividend is from a business
perspective it's based on what their
company is able to return if it's not at
a profitable year then it's not going to
pay as high a dividend I think Council
has struggled with that sometimes in the
past but I mean I take into account the
fact that
that projected dividend is created with
the best knowledge at at the time but
it's just Council understanding the
tension and expectation on ichl in this
case on what that dividend is
if we go inside of them sorry if we go
inside of them we want an increased
dividend then they'll say well let's
find we need more money to go and invest
in opportunities that will help to
increase that dividend
um three two that's fair as well as
making sure that we've been very clear
when we giving our dividend expectations
to the Holdings company that we want a
steady dividend we don't want it to be
up one year and then
significantly different the next we need
that steady return
um let's take like slightly less than
one year to get more the next year and I
think they have used an element of
smoothing in the past they do
Tom
um two questions
are you taking questions have you got uh
how many more slides we got there is two
more slides okay sorry I'll ask you to
the end of that yeah yeah
it's a very important one about the
asset plan
um the asset plan's done as part of the
wider property asset plan but we do have
one for these and then the last slide
was the risks and challenges that we
have
um because like I'm the only one that's
used the risks and challenges slow but
with investment property
we are dealing with risk risk and return
on this so we lose tenants
um there's and we're going to have the
opportunities
um we do have endowment funds where we
have to keep investing so it's just
finding those opportunities
with the Holdings is that maximizing
that long-term dividend
and make and keeping that alignment
of to council's vision and objectives
and Treasury
these are macroeconomic risks and
challenges we have with treated with the
treasury side and that's just the
interest rate fluctuations and then
having that really good visibility of
our borrowing to ensure that we know
when we need to go borrow
and for how much there's no use going to
borrow
30 million today because you know we've
got a 70 million or 50 million dollar
Capital plan for the year
but if I go borrow 30 million today I
might not need to go borrow again
because they might not have spent it all
so it's just balancing that
Tom
um so two questions this very early
slide that you showed that had the um
budget I guess on it you know revenue
and
there was a a cost of two and a half
million dollars a year or something like
that I don't know if you want to try to
go back to that slide so
um operational expenditure 2.2 million
so what does that include interest
expense
pardon interest expense oh it's interest
expense so that sits as an expense so
it's down in the operating expenditure
for Treasury
okay so same question which maybe you've
just answered by the first question
um
if we
look at the Investments that we have see
it you know nichl
this is a term exceed the
um rate of interest on the
boardings that we have
I mean that infrastructure returns level
returns so there are tons of decimal
it's very small at the moment returns
very small so basically if I subtract
2.2 from 7.4 I get five
um the the
um total
value of those assets would be around
500 million or something or 400 million
dollars
so
um you know you're looking at one or two
percent
return on assets I need to have a double
right and it may be three or four
percent or something like that return on
equity
but you know the bordering rig seeds out
at the moment so I mean I I guess I I
just come back to we've discussed this
before whether
um it would be more sensible for us to
um
uh
no longer ruin some of those in retired
debt and I don't know we've ever came
here okay in the final I've never really
had an explanation of why we would we
would not do that
um and it may be that it's an
appropriate thing to do but just kind of
Prima face so if you look at numbers
you know you really would say well you
know why it's get such a low return yeah
and why would we want to continue
winning those assets
that has a question actually
and that's a question that we need to
look more closely at during the MTP yeah
I just kind of feel as though we we
lately rub against that question in
several sessions with ever really again
to
announce it
great
well Michael's got a question no I'm
sorry Michael
yeah thank you through yourself too I
can answer a little bit of what um Tom's
trying to allude to in relation to that
um
with the
the Gap that you talk about in the
dividend Associated to your holding
company
any reduction From perspective the sales
proceeds will impact on your ability to
borrow because we're we can borrow based
on our net revenue more gross revenue I
should say impact side of it so that
changes your debt cap it's our debt caps
not based on our asset base it's based
on our ability to create revenue from
that perspective and cover that
so if you sell assets to reduce your
debt you're reducing your ability to
borrow at the same time so you could
take that into account and and this is
where Patricia would need to do some
work is looking at which actually has a
better financial position for you having
a less dip cap
or actually having that investment in
something like your whole your whole
coin getting a dividend so those
components do need to look be looked at
in relation to that
um
the other side I would say in relation
to the holding company per se is that's
not really a about a significant debt
component from that perspective yes it
would have an impact being able to
reduced it for Council but we don't
actually lend now to holding company
directly we've got indirect components
going on on different parts but not
directly to them but we do allow
provision in our accounts which is why
we get a high credit rating is because
we're allowing that provision from our
accounts perspective it's one of our
safeguards as a council having that
provision there whether that's looked at
at some stage that's something to
consider for your treasury as well yeah
I look my simplest question at the
simplest form would be do we gain or
lose money by owning holco
yes
There's an opportunity for
tax advantages that sits within the
holding company as well
which I guess we also have to add as a
form of income would that be fair
Michael I just won't leave that to
Patricia Anthony it was okay
fortunately there's been a leadership
it's not the tips I wanted to hear
there has been
um some advantages with having the
holding company from a text perspective
um but that is something that we will
come back with as part of financial
strategy
Grant thanks to you yeah I think we're
leaning into that with the in August
aren't we with
a sort of whole co-review and financial
strategy yeah because I think and it's
my questions or statements similar to
Toms
you know I suspect that holco is largely
just an asset management entity as
opposed to an Investment Portfolio
business so
you know in in summer discussion that's
been here today or you know we give them
a Target rate of return and that's all
they achieve we don't know whether they
could achieve more than that or we
certainly don't want them to achieve
less so I think we do need to have a
really good look at
you know a strategic asset play
understand the debt cat thing but you
know would be we'll be releasing a lot
of debt at four percent borrowing cost
and we lose a little bit of capacity in
our debt cap from five million bucks for
the revenue so I would say the obviously
it would be advantageous and then it may
be if we decide to change to an
Investment Portfolio approach to holco
we create capacity and balance sheet to
chase higher returns now that comes with
risk I understand that but we certainly
need to be trying to drive the maximum
return
from there portfolio within a risky but
to try and offset some of the cost we've
just covered in the previous sessions
around you know costs aren't going
backwards so we've got to drive assets
harder
so I think you know that's
where we need to head to and so when
will we get
wins that discussion August August and
we'll get the sufficient papers to
support it
what was it real
26th of September so so we'll get those
papers on those investment returns and
I'll get I'll have some information for
you ahead of time for that one thank you
cheers
thank you other questions or comments
sorry okay yeah just with regard to
investment properties what's the capital
value of those investment properties
roughly
17 minutes oh no we just did the
valuation done
17 17 yeah 17 million
and what are the
restrictive barriers to
divesting those assets
debt on some of those so some of those
are fully debt funded at the moment
um and a lot of them are endowment funds
so their funds have to come back into
the benefit of the city
so it's restrictive and what you can use
the funds for
they have Perpetual tenants on them as
well some of them
so
um but they could potentially become
purchases right correct yeah yep
thank you no further questions or
feedback
thank you
thank you Brianna are you comfortable
with where we're at
having having taken the feedback it'll
all be note down and form part of what
comes back to us through the ltp process
so um councilors people had a sheep for
their options you've had today so if you
can provide your feedback
that will be used to shape up the final
asset and activity plans which we've
brought back views which has four
decisions so if you could have those
available in about a week that would be
awesome thank you thank you and thanks
to those that have joined us on the live
stream that concludes this afternoon's
Workshop